т та бачимо пана бондара неочікувано Я
вас вітаю перш за все Я вас вітаю із
днем незалежності з 30ї вже річницю Що
для вас це свято і і одразу хочу сказати
що тут і маруся звіробій видатна
українка Що для вас це свято для мене в
першу чергу це воля і Свобода 30 років
відновлення незалежності ми дійсно
держава з багаторічною історією
тисячолітньою історією і ці 30 років ми
боремося за свою незалежність і останні
с років зі зброєю в руках виборюємо її
дякуючи о таким як Маруся дякуючи таким
як побратими тут поряд ми її виборюємо
тому 30 років Незалежності в першу чергу
це знакове тому що 7 років назад хлопці
і дівчата стали на захист держави якби
не вони цей би 30тиріччя не було би не
було Тому це знакова дата тобто після
анексії Криму після анексії Донбасу - Це
перша кругла дата яку ми відстояли
відвоювали 30 років і я впевнений що
буде 40 50 і дальше І
дальше Маруся я знаю що тут є 100%
багато людей яких ти тренувала Тому що
власне ти займалася вишколом коли ти
бачиш ріки потоки наших ветеранів наших
військових і героїв чи думалатив
коли-небудь що в нас ну настільки
могутня держава Так я про це думаю
постійно це кінцева задача і якщо ми за
неї взялись колись то доки ми її не
здобудемо ніхто не розійдеться і будуть
марші ветеранів тому що країна має
бачити не лише тих на чиїх плечах лежить
держава сьогодні але і тих хто виніс цю
державу на своїх плечах вчора тому
надзвичайно важливо збирати тут
ветеранів Це в тому числі для них
реабілітація бачити один одного і ба
чити людей які не втомлюються
боротися я не можу не відзначити
сьогодні вашу форму Тому що це вже схоже
на геть нові стандарти того як готують
військових розкажіть про це тому що дуже
часто українці думають що в нас армія
лишається ще старих стандартів але
сьогодні ви виглядаєте надзвичайно
сучасно я виглядаю сучасно але на жаль
це не є українська форма це є форма
французького іноземного легіону це
підрозділ в якому я також служив від
відслуживши два роки своєї армії я хтмів
перейняти досвід контрактної армії і
пішов туди служити І сьогодні я її однів
по одній простій причині я хочу сказати
що шановні партнери шановні друзі Ми вже
давним-давно готові до вступу в НАТО Я
сьогодні оцією формою хочу закликати
все-таки ми ще в восьмому скликанні
прийняли закон де пропонуємо вести
миротворчу місію на Донбас для цьго щоб
звільнити наші території французький
іноземний Легіон має досвід номер один в
миротворчих місіях сьогодні цим я хочу
підкреслити що з початку війни на наших
теренах
американці британці інші країни своїми
інструкторами допомагають нам вчитися як
як виборювати в тому числі нашу
незалежність тому я сьогодні в такій
формі щоб сказати шановні
Ми чекаємо Ми думаємо що буквально
завтра має статися так що ви нас
запросите в НАТО і Україна там буде я
дякую вам і дякую за Ваш вклад і
розбудову нашої держави особливо тобі Ми
продовжуємо спілкуватися із тими людьми
хто прийшов сьогодні на марш патріотів
пан Олександр Турчинов колишній
екссекретар РНБО пане Олександре ну перш
за все із днем незалежності Скажіть будь
ласка сьогодні розпитую про символи і
значення цього свята для кожного що ви
відчуваєте 30 років ви знаєте Головне що
ми отримали за 30 років - Це націю
вільних людей націю воїнів яка здатна
захистити свою країну і сьогодні ви
бачите на цьому марші марші патріотів
об'єднались ті хто захищав Україну на
Майдані Хто першими ставав в проломі
коли агресор напав на нашу державу 14-му
році і сьогодні це і військові і
волонтери і ті патріоти які
працювали в тиру з на зміцненні нашої
оборони Тобто це якраз марш єднання
України і сьогодні ви бачите скільки
десятків тисяч людей приймають в ньому
участь пане Олександре Я сьогодні
спостерігала за тим як українці
зустрічали військових під час параду Я
впевнена що ніхто не очікував такої
кількості техніки такої кількості
літаків і що Так будуть виглядати наші
військові Ви відчуваєте що Ну це вже
прірва між 14-м і сьогоднішнім як багато
було зроблено для того аби наша армія
увійшла в топ-25 враховуючи Скільки ви
свого часу для цього робили безумовно Ну
ви знаєте це дуже таке яскраве відчуття
коли бачиш наскільки стало сильніше наша
армія наші збройні сили Наші всі
військові формування Я починаю з чого ми
починали коли не було жодної кілаврої
казки коли не було жодного бронежилета
коли хлопці в джинсах в кедах з
автоматами йшли проти російських танків
тому що треба було захищати країну Це
безумовно дуже серйозний крок але в той
же час я подивився що за 2 по роки
фактично у нас на превеликий жаль не
з'явилось нових розробок техніки тобто
фактично то що ми бачили на параді це
результат роботи 14-го 18го років і це
серйозна проблема тому
що сучасна війна потребує постійного
удосконалення і зброї і військової
техніки а навпаки багато Вибачте тої
бронетехніки або тих самих катерів які
сьогодні приймав участь в параді вони
проходять в вічдоках в замовних справах
які чинна Влада саме розкручує для того
щоби позбавитись своїх політичних
опонентів Але ж це дуже сильно б'є по
безпеці обороні нашої держави Ну тут я
би окремо вас запитала про те що зараз я
бачу як українці приходять і підтримують
українських військових як вони за них
вболівають і ними пишаються але якщо
подивитися на останні справи І на те як
влада і держава підтримує військових
волонтерів ветеранів ато то виходить що
в нас на сьогоднішній день відбувається
певна зачистка патріотичного частини
населення Чи розумієте ви причини а
найголовніше наслідки от якщо б всіх цих
людей не було де б були ми і що би з
нами було ви знаєте якраз
е багато із тих хто сьогодні є
фігурантами штучних висасаних з пальця
кримінальних справ якраз вони ставали в
правомі за Україну саме вони захищали її
коли чинні керівники давали концерти в
Москві або на окупованих територіях і це
безумовно прикра тому що в першу чергу
це дуже сильний удар саме по
обороноздатності нашої країни Коли
оборонні підприємства які здатні робити
висококласну техніку і ми її бачили
сьогодні фактично блокуються коли третій
рік поспіль зривається державне оборонне
замовлення і не інансовується саме
розробка новітньої техніки це є проблема
парад - це безумовно дуже важливо парад
- це красиво це Гідність це сила нашої
країни але є питання які на параді не
побачиш і це питання саме зміцнення
обороноздатності нашої держави і тут є
багато-багато проблем які треба негайно
вирішувати і на превеликий жаль чинна
Влада більше приймається піаром
красивими видови щми красивими
відеозверненнями Ані конкретною щоденною
роботою на розбудови збройних сил на
посилення нашого сектора безпеки і
оборони але Бачите як ми бачимо що дуже
велика частина активного суспільства яка
точно буде підганяти і нашу Владу і
тримати руку на пульсі І власне як це
робите просто зараз ви Ми дякуємо вам
пане Олександре ще раз зі святом
Олександр Турчинов був з нами Ми ж
продовжимо відслідковувати марш
патріотів просто зараз коробка за
коробкою продовжують рухатись Бачите ми
навіть поки що неснули із місця Все
тільки тому що так багато В нас
ветеранів так багато героїв які прийшли
я як і обіцяла ми будемо продовжувати
писати так із коробок наших військових
наших патріотів буде дуже багато класних
включень дочекайтесь і Слідкуйте за
нашою
трансляцією
независимо я был военнослужащим
Советской Армии я служил в западной
группе войск и уже тогда у нас началась
такая себе грзня с представителями
России они начали говорить вы хохлы
пропадёте что вы без нас будете делать
тогда уже начались вопросы а Если вдруг
война кто с кем будет воевать тогда в 91
году мы не совсем осознали то что мы
получили я скажу больше наверное Даже и
в 2000 году не до всех до нас дошло что
вс-таки независимость Украины - это
очень важно 14й год перевернул нас всех
14чей год нам в правила мозги и в 14том
году Когда мы начали за свою
независимость платить кровью мы тогда
действительно поняли насколько это важно
для нашей страны быть действительно
независимыми быть действительно
свободными сравните Украину и сравните
например Россию Как говорится ну тюрма
народов Как была так собствено і
осталось ну Але тим не менше пане Вадиме
от ми маємо цифри цифри ці до певної
міри песимістичні вони стверджують про
те що кожен третій України сьогодні
сумує за радянським союзом і згідно з
останнім опитуванням групи рейтинг кожен
третій фактично українець 31% голосував
би сьогодні за збрадження Радянського
Союзу А вас особисто ця цифра бентежить
особливо на восьмому році війни з
Російською Федерацією вона в якомусь
періоді почала мене бентежити Мабуть що
останні півтора-два роки тому що це
навіювання і ілюзія Як бачите сьогодні
руйнується тим що сьогодні люди реально
збиті однією силою і їх поєднує Одне те
що колись років два тому на віявилось як
ілюзія армія Віра мова сьогодні це
працює на об'єднання націй Ці основні
цінності якщо згадувати рейтингування то
саме армія Сьогодні має саме великий
рівень довіри Ніхто з політиків можливо
таких теперішніх немає тих що керують
країною Якщо говорити про це сакральне
місце зверніть увагу бульвар Шевченка і
бувший постамент для ідола Леніна те що
здавалось би колись для імперії було
закономірно і ніхто не вірив в ту ідею
що це має відбутися відбулося зруйновано
абсолютно всі ознаки імперії ми маємо
вільну самостійну державу і в це не
потрібно проводити рейтингування це
варто глянути на всі вулиці сьогодні
українські де виходять молодь і діти і
поєднано говорять про одне що це наша
незалежна держава я більше чим впевнений
що ці заклики які сьогодні звучать як
Україна понад усе це мрія омріяна наших
лідерів визвольних рухів всіх
українських І сьогодні ми на щастя маємо
велике силу в тому що є наша армія яка
нас захищає і той народ який сьогодні ту
армію спільно забезпечив як волонтери
Так І кожен із нас хто долучався і
безумовно що здавалось би та ілюзія для
когось про безвіз яка колись була і
навіювала що ми не отримаємо ніколи
сьогодні так само є зруйнована я більше
чим впевнений і Ми впевнені в тому що ми
отримаємо членство повноцінно в ЄС і в
НАТО і в тому наша сила Олексію справді
збройні сили України - Це те чим
пишається абсолютна більшість українців
це те що сьогодні надихає і створює
враження захищеності наскільки сьогодні
збройні сили України отримують належну
підтримку з боку держави Наскільки Ви
сьогодні відчуваєте як ветеран війни як
людина яка готова буде в потрібний
момент встати на захист країни так само
як і абсолютно більшість українців
Наскільки Ви відчуваєте сьогодні
здатність держави забезпечити те що
потрібно військовослужбовцям ну К
сожалению в 19-м году вот помощь Армии
от государства у нас поставили на паузу
я звон в батальон Спасите любо
последний раз боевойе
ла нанимали 2019 года сейчас про Армии
вспоминают у меня Такое ощущение что
наверное за 3 дня до каких-то праздников
и через день после праздника к сожалению
никаких новых разработок нету все
прекрасно знают что государственный
оборонный заказ провален Владимир
Зеленский сегодня говорил возможно
хорошие правильные пахосные основа но к
сожалениюго дальше слов Дело не уходит а
ведь ни политики ни банковая
5 ртал ни Зеленский ни ермаки все
остальные они берегут по по для всей
нашей страны для Киева для всех десятков
тысяч людей которы находятся здесь а
именно Украина именно армия Украины
именно ВСУ подразделения национальной
гварди добровольческие подразделения и
именно сегодня им в народ сндуют Дякую И
вы смотрите что творится закончился
парад вроде бы народ должен разойтись
нет остались ждут аплодируют и мы бачимо
что навпаки кількість людей зростає по
всяк час люди підходять і ідхо 60 100
000 то есть трудно почитать вот это
оценка собственно та оценка действиям
власти ведь в 19м году команда
Зеленского решила не проводить парад в
первые завоенное годе заменив его фразой
что мы дадим деньги солдатам солдатам
так лучше не могу понять откуда
Зеленский знает что лучше солдатам схоже
солдатам в 2020 году тоже самое
попытались стереть грани нуно народ
сказал окей хорошо вы не хотите мы сами
проведём у нас у самих Всё получится и
прошлось и получилось в Дем году и в
20том году в этом году всё-таки когда
рейтинги стали падать решили что-то
менять решили провести парад хорошо
Молодцы Окей нуно народ уже говорит
хорошо парад парадом но мы всё равно
приведем свой парад я вам скажу больше в
следующем году то же самое
буде взагалі наскільки от доречна
традиція яка склалася останніми роками
проводити окреме марш патріотів окремо
від оційної частини може є сенс все це
поєднати І чи взагалі ви як депутат
кільської міської ради Що можете сказати
про те немає спроб якимось чином
завадити проведення всіх заходів з боку
офційних
влади Я думаю що у владі теперішній не
по зубах волонтерства не по зубах
активність людей і ця традиція
закономірно я підтримує Олексія про те
що це вже встановлена традиція і
безумовно це невід'ємна Скажем так і
історія і то що протамано філософію і
душ в українство подякувати захисникам
тому що люди які сьогодні реально
підходять ви абсолютно праві підходять
все більше людей для того щоби вшанувати
І подякувати і впевнений в тому що ця
традиція буде підтримана і утримана те
що було колись я вже недаремно згадував
нав'язування імперські і знищення
пам'яті як такої На жаль для влади
теперішньої не вдалося і нівелювання
достоїнства і заслуг доброботів так само
не вдалося е знищення оборонного
замовлення за останні два роки і ті
достатки і той то достоїнство війська
яке сьогодні ми споглядали всі на параді
можна легко дізнатися що ця техніка
випущена якраз в роки починаючи з 15-го
по 19-й рік і зрозуміло що якщо ми як
волонтери пам'ятаємо в чому ця армія
була наша українська одягнена як вона
знищувалась в тому числі так званими
шостою колоною яка сиділа в кабінетах
СБУ МВД і так далі які сьогодні сидять
на території Російської Федерації
безумовно що це Владу теперішнью Має
спонукати до дії безумовно що останні
два роки якраз цього дефіциту і
справлості українського суспільства
спонукали владу провести саме такий до
достойний порад щоби показати ворогу що
в нас є достойні охоронці нашого спокою
люди мають бути впевнені в тому що вони
є захищеними люди мають бути впевнені в
своїй армії І в своїй
державі
Олексію 30тиріччя незалежності України
очевидно той період коли ми можемо ну
підбивати вже певні підсумки і говорити
про те наскільки українці самі
ставляться схвально до своєї держави от
Нове покоління українців народжене вже
після 91го року воно виразно
відрізняється від своїх батьків в тому
числі в тому сенсі який стосується
підтримки курсу на європейську
євроатлантичну інтеграцію ми бачимо що
молоде покоління українців не хоче себе
себе на відміну від частини їхніх
батьків асоціювати із радянським минулим
яку роль в цьому виконує ну в в цій
скажемо так в правильному доброму
розумінні пропаганді способу життя Яку
роль виконують засоби масової інформації
зокрема телебачення чи достатньо
документальних стрічок художніх стрічок
які розповідають про історію Украины К
сожалению недостаточно и это мягко
сказано ведь сейчас если посчитать
современные фильмы исторические фильмы
которые раскрывают историю нашей страны
не только XXI века а XX веков 19 то их
можно будет перечитать на пальцах одной
руки вы посмотрите Что делается в России
вкладываются колоссальные деньги в
пропаганду а не фильмы А так
называемойли стной войне клепаются
скоростью пулемта у нас снимают всё что
угодно только не исторические фильмы не
фильмы про войну не фильмы которые
раскрывают ужас голодомора и так далее А
ведь информационная война информационная
агрессия она не то что очень Важна она
безумно Важна в нашем в нашей жизни и
вспоминаем 14 год Сколько нам на голову
выливали дезинформации Сколько нам на
голову выливали фейков как народ на это
вёлся что-то изменилось Нет просто мы
должны прекрасно понимать что это не
закончится завтра если завтра
послезавтра дай Бог перестанут стрелять
пушки на Донбассе Донбасс будет
деоккупирован Потом будет деоккупирован
Крым А он обязательно будет
деоккупирован война Не закончится Россия
нас никогда не оставит в покое и мы
должны готовиться полномасштабному
вторжению как горячему так Скажем так
информационному готовится не сегодня
готовится позавчера и есть Скажем так
сказали Древние хорошую Прекрасную фразу
пасом парабелом хочешь мера готов вся
Ну і Вадиме очевидно ще фінальне
запитання стосовно саміту Кримської
платформи який відбувався напередодні
23го числа куди прибули представники 44х
країн та організацій на вашу думку що
зараз найбільше потрібно для як
найшвидше де окупації Криму чого зараз
Україні бракує найбільше для того щоби
повернути в першу чергу в інформаційний
порядок денний півострів і не тільки
міжнародний але й український тому що на
жаль навіть в Україні говорять все менше
і менше абсолютно ми втратили свої
позиції за останній період не тільки з
цього питання на міжнародній арені і для
мене так само якийсь постсовєтизм що
саме до Дня Незалежності було оце
засідання Кримської платформи нічого не
заважало протягом півтора-2 року влади
Зеленського якщо це була така ідеологія
і теза зробити це значно раніше що варто
робити варто спілкуватися і реально
відбудовувати діалоги і з людьми які
проживають на території Криму показати
своїм прикладом українства які є на
території вільної України від
загарбників російських що ми є успішною
країною ми забезпечиємо спокій сьогодні
недаремно в колоні якраз Кримській було
чутно дуже прості і закономірні слова
українські військові самі сильні і самі
гарні на планеті
Земля Ну що ж колеги як ми бачимо триває
марш патріотів який розпочався зараз
хрчатикам колони рухаються загалом
кажуть понад 60 коробок колони рухається
бульваром Тараса Шевченка донизу до
весаеранки потають на хречатах до
Майдану Незалежності традиційно місця
ушанування і святкування Ми сьогодні
спілкувалися в прямому ефірі з нашими
двома гостями Олексій Петров ветеран
російсько-української війни і Вадим
сторжук депутат Київської міської ради Я
Тарас Березовець на цьому на цій частині
наш ефір закінчи ми будемо рухатися до
нашої наступної точки де чекатимуть на
нас вже наші наступні спікери Ну а
святковий Марафон на кіль кох
українських телевізійних каналах нагадаю
телеканал прямий п'ятий Еспресо триває
тож будемо І далі включатися з
найсвижішими нови нами
колеги набть все дякую
акуратно с ни
от Я не знаю дивіться
сза я сказала я знаю ваша
задачанятипеномі Героям
слава
раніше я не вважаю не не сказала би що в
нас була повна незалежність вона нам
здобулась дуже легко тобто фактично без
ніякої боротьби а от саме з 14-го року
Дійсно я інші ветерани і побратими
посестри Ми виборювали цю нашу свободу
нашу незалежність своєю кров'ю потом
стражданням і боротьбою тому дійсно це
свято мабуть Для мене одне із самих
пам'ятних найпам'ятніше і я надзвичайно
тішусь його провести разом з своїми
побратимами та посестрами розкажіть про
вашу коробку тому що те що стосується
госпітальєрі це стало вже абсолютно
легендою те що роблять військові польові
медики ми бачимо що тут так багато
молоді дівчат хто всі ці Як ви сказали
побратими і посестри як ви формувалися
як знаходили одне одного чому Всі пішли
на фронт Ну тут зосереджені досить різні
люди ви можете навіть якщо повернете
камеру побачити скільки тут людей це все
наші госпітальєри вони приєдналися до
батальйону в різні роки тобто
починається від 14-го навіть до є ті які
приєднались в цьому році вік абсолютно
різний від 18 і нам нашому старшому
госпітальєру 80 років він прийшов на
фронт в 14-му в
73 тут є як лікарі так і спеціалісти
цивільних професій
студенти Люди які працюють вдома ну
тобто абсолютно різноманітні але всіх їх
об'єднує ідея рятувати життя і тому у
нас і є такий лозунг заради кожного
життя інколи можна почути слова
розчарування про те що щось не склалося
чогось ми не зробили за 30 років що
довго триває війна що опускаються руки Я
впевнена що Можливо колись такі думки і
почуття приходять до вас що ви говорите
Як ви боретесь і яку надію вкладаєте
кожного разу особливо в таку велику дату
як 30 років Незалежності мабуть якісь
періоди зневіри в мене були ще там Через
д-три роки від початку війни тому що
хотілося щоб було швидше щоб ми швидше
могли здобувати і звільняти наші
території але з дійсно не все так як
хочеться тому я себе переламала і той
етап прожила І зараз я мабуть уже працюю
тому що треба працювати тягнути цю ношу
я розумію що бів батальйону крім мене
ніхто не потягне і в мене вже Просто
немає іншого вибору у 14-му році геть
усі українці докладалися до того аби
фінансувати допомагати армії ми всі
розуміли що це гроші це різна-різна
допомога і з часом оцей зв'язок
суспільства і армії Він все ж таки став
меншим що сьогодні яка допомога на
найбільше потрібна це люди це підтримка
це інформаційна підтримка От чого б ви
Якби можна було попросити просто зараз
би це зробили ну мабуть найбільше Це нам
потрібне найактуальніше це продукти
харчування і заправка там талони Це
мабуть те що витрачається просто
найбільше коштів тому що так людей вже
трішки вистачає продуктів деяких також
ніби нам допомагають волонтери на
позиціях нам Звісно ж також стараються
трішки допомагати ваякі Але все рівно ці
витрати мабуть більше тягнуть ресурсив і
як мені не прикро говорити це комунальні
послуги нашого нашої бази тому що як не
крути вже часи коли все надавалось
безкоштовно минуле тепер оплачується і
оренда і оплачуються повністю всі
комунальні послуги а ми всі знаємо
скільки воно коштує і на останок от якщо
вас спитати Чим найбільше ви пишаєтеся
за 30 років Незалежності етап факт подія
що що найбільше вас надихає І що
говорить про те що точно вже не буде як
раніше і ми йдемо тільки вперед
так Мабуть за ці всі роки мене найбільше
надихає оця можливість об'єднання наших
громадян тому що як ви пам'ятаєте в
14-му об'єдналися геть усі починаючи як
на Майдані так і опісля по допомоги
армії тому що це дуже важка ноша і
реально мені імпонувало як всі
згуртовано збиралися в школах біля шкіл
там батьки збирали якісь продукти дітки
малювали малюнки тобто кожен старався
зробити якісь свій внесок і реально оцей
феномен нашої об'єднаності феномен
волонтерства феномен добровольців він і
не дав Росії а відграбити стільки наших
земель Тобто ми велику частину змогли
відвоювати і реально вони навіть собі
такого уявити не могли Тому нам є чим
пишатися і це мабуть таке Найбільше мені
відклалось до душі це чиста правда Я
дуже вам дякую Дякую за те що ви робили
всі ці роки Дякую за те що згуртували
довкола себе людей і справді цю єдність
ми можемо бачити просто зараз Яна
Зінкевич людина про яку можна багато
говорити і народна депутатка військовий
медик волонтер Ну і власне згуртовані
сьогодні її можна цілий день бачити як
на параді під час святкування 30тиріччя
незалежності України та і просто зараз
коли ми вже спостерігаємо за маршем
патріотів де безліч купа фантастичних
українців які долучилися до того аби
сьогодні показати що українське
суспільство - це одна єдина сила і Ми
продовжуємо слідкувати за цим маршем
Ходімо
єємоуємо
яла
друзі я хочу сказати що так трапилося що
ми досі не зрушили з жодного місця ну
тобто я знала що в нас велика кількість
патріотів я знала що в нас велика
кількість військових і ще Минулого року
ми побачили оцю годинну ходу Коли ріки
людей неслися але сьогодні направду таке
відчуття що їх стало Ще більше і от
безкінечно коробка за коробкою наших
патріотів наших героїв вони йдуть
центром Ну а просто зараз поки ми
чекаємо свого часу я знайшла Олександра
погрибицького Я впевнена що більшості
наших телеглядачам навіть не треба
нагадувати але мені приємно сказати що
це Ветеран АТО і депутат Київради пане
Олександре ну перш за все Я вітаю вас
сьогоднішнім святом 30 років
Незалежності але ви особисто на фронті
відстоювали
це свято і цю подію з якими думками ви
йшли на фронт що вело вас чому пішли
захищати
державу перш за все це мій обов'язок як
громадянина України закріплений в
Конституції України і саме з відчуттям
обов'язку я йшов на фронт я не
військовий я не кадровий військовий Я
інженер За освітою якби але коли війна
коли в Україні Відкрита рана яку атакує
Ворог мій обов'язок внутрішній і
моральний піти і захистити мою країну
тому я вирішив і прийняв рішення піти на
фронт ви один із співорганізаторів маршу
ветеранів і патріотів Як так сталося як
народилася ця ідея і найголовніше знаєте
інколи сумно що ми бачимо оцю паралель
коли свято державне а потім військові і
ветерани вони окремо Як так сталося що
на сьогоднішній день Влада не отут
президент не Тут поруч з вами де він мав
би бути чому
так Ну по-перше це вже традиційний марш
він проводиться дуже давно потужним і
найбільшим як марш протест проти того що
пам'ятаєте в 19-му році не відбувся
ві люди хочуть вийти на День
незалежності для того щоб показати свою
єдність підрозділів організацій
і відсвяткувати свято незалежності
країни чому тут немає Зеленського Ну так
вже традиційно склалось що з 2019 року
він боїться всіх цих людей в нас дуже
багато політв'язнів саме ветеранів це
рів це Юля Кузьменко Це Яна
дугар це інші ветерани
хлопці
тому йому страшно дивитись в очі цим
людям бо вони будуть питати вони будуть
запитувати
Сьогодні ми зранку були на військовому
параді бо для нас честь шанувати наших
побратимів які зараз на службі зі зброєю
в руках захищають нашу незалежність Тому
це наш обов'язок прийти І шанувати її
так само як і будь-якіх громадян які там
були і далі ми вже після офіційного
параду проводимо свій марш нехай
Зеленський бачить цю кількість людей і
нехай Зеленський робить висновки те що
він створює якусь картинку патріотичну
не значить що ці люди повірили в цей
фарс і в цю ілюзію ці люди будуть чітко
слідкувати те щоб не відбувалась
державна зрада в Україні вони будуть
моментально виходити і протестувати ці
люди
будуть слідкувати за тим що відбувається
в Збройних силах
України зараз тут Республіка брати зброї
це наша ветеранська організація близько
тисяч ветеранів в різних коробках
прийшли сьогодні
сюди це це Генерали це офіцери це
сержанти і це солдати це люди з різних
підрозділів з добробатів ЗСУ з дшв І
абсолютно з різних військ і вони просто
так не дозволять здати нашу країну і
просто так не дозволять зруйнувати всі
ті надбання які наші збройні сили і наша
Україна дуже з великим з великими
втратами набула за останніх сім род
Дякуємо пане Олександре і не дасть цього
же зробити українське суспільство бачимо
як багато українців сьогодні прийшли вам
вас підтримати Дякуємо ще раз зі святом
друзі А я хочу звернути вашу увагу на те
що українські військові - це
представники геть усіх вікових категорій
від наймолодших до вже абсолютно
дорослих чоловіків і жінок тобто навіть
Я не знаю як вирахувати середній вік
українського патріота Мені здається що
це абсолютно кожен українець хто відчув
від 14-го року бажання захищати нашу
державу і оту небезпеку про яку сьогодні
так багато говорять наші ветерани
небезпека яка прийшла на нашу територію
і яка сказала що наша незалежність під
питанням її треба захищати але фронти
бувають різні військові а бувають ще й
дипломатичні просто зараз бачу Валерія
Чалого надзвичайного і повноважного
посла українського пан Я вас вітаю із
30ю у вас річницею от скажіть Я просто
зараз розповідаю нашим глядачам що є
різні фронти де треба захищати
незалежність у вас був світ це
дипломатичний і я впевнена що за всі ці
роки дуже багато кулуарних було розмов А
може розвернути Україну а може вона має
бути придатком до якоїсь держави як
встояли як вберегли
незалежність ви знаєте Я в принципі можу
згадати з 90х років оце три революції на
граниті потім оранжева революція і потім
революція
Я думаю це віхи але ясно що 2014 рік
починаючи з Майдана і жертв Небесної
Сотні за що Ну просто низький поклін цим
хлопцям і дівчатам і жінкам і чоловікам
які нас тоді захистили від свавілля
режиму і дали Україні нормальний шлях в
майбутнє і далі вони же перші пішли
волонтерами на фронт тому дійсно такого
як після російської атаки ніколи не було
І от цей момент
це друга хвиля Коли Україна виборала
свою незалежність я думаю що якщо ви
питаєте про дипломатів чи там інших
людей Всі в цей момент об'єднались всі
об'єднались і зробили свою справу Але
Одна справа зробити крок а інша
витримати цей натиск і зараз Ми
продовжуємо цю боротьбу Ну я думаю що що
могли зробити дипломати - це
забезпечити нашу армію флот авіацію
надійною зброєю ви пам'ятаєте коли
йшли колони в перший раз покрищчаатику
Сьогодні другий раз це вже відбувалось а
в перший раз ішли ще за президента
Порошенка коли оці от коробки чи
підрозділи іноземні йшли на нашій
території я пам'ятаю як я розмовляв як
посол України сполучених штатав і казав
нам дуже потрібно щоб це був міністр
оборони будь ласка вирішить Я особисто
просив про це Генерала метіса дуже
поважно людину і коли Тут були
американці коли тут був міністр оборони
США коли всі виступили з нами то
дипломати звісно змогли в цих країнах
забезпечити і летальну
зброю ми в Америці зробили дживеліни
протитанкову зброю ви пам'ятаєте коли
під мар'нкою тоді не захотіли сідати в
танки тільки тому що пішов слух що вже
живелі не тут Тому ці всі це все
об'єднано це можна називати фронтами Але
я вважаю фронт це тільки один це там де
волонтери те там де наша армія флот
авіація реально професійно захищають
нашу країну то льний флот ми дипломати
допомагаємо цьому і будемо робити все
від нас залежне для того щоб Україна
встояла була незалежною відновила
територіальну цілосність і йшла
правильним шляхом шляхом євроатлантичним
шляхом повернення не тільки географічно
історично і культурно але й політично
економічно соціально до єдиної Європи до
єдиного євроатлантичного простору пане
Валерію ні для кого не секрет що
небезпека нікуди не пішла нещодавно ми
побачили як дуже легко російські війська
можуть підійти до наших кордонів І це
означає що єдність гуртованість
підтримка військових має бути все ще на
першому місці не другому третьому а
основа основ на сьогоднішній день ви
бачите от відверто Цей курс тому що
військові розповідають про провалене
оборонне замовлення про те що
відбувається на фронті і українське
суспільство хоче знати Ми ж так
підтримували військо чи зараз наша влада
так само це номером один тримає і
контролює ну свято знаєте хочеться
більше горити про цих героїв і про всіх
воїнів які тут зібрались Я не знаю тут
70 000 я не знаю скільки тут людей оця
мотивація і їх бажання Це те що надихає
Але дійсно армія не може воювати без
зброї сучасної якщо на початках коли
цього не було засобів захищеної
комунікації дуже багато гинуло людей
зз-за цього тому звісно я також можу
сказати Хочу свято але все-таки державне
оборонне замовлення тре треба вчасно
приймати виділяти кошти в бюджеті на
закупівлю нових систем протиповітряної
оборони нам треба підсилюватися на флоті
і проблема в тому що це треба робити
негайно зараз тому що незабаром навчання
російські що буде далі Куди ця зброя
піде ми не знаємо ви бачите що нікуди
загроза не пішла тому свята це ще одне
нагадування що треба мати мотивовану
патріотичну частину народу який готовий
захищати свою країну і друге це частину
патріотичною армію треба озброїти так
щоби менше гинуло наших воїнів і тому я
буду
вимагати і роблю це щоби максимально
забезпечилась армія тому що я думаю
кожна гривня вкладена зараз в армію флот
авіацію це економія дуже велика на
майбутнє І я хотів би щоб так всі
депутати Всі політики розглядали
сьогодні завдання в першу чергу безпека
а потім вже всі інші питання не буде
захищений людина і країна тоді нічого не
буде Дякуємо вам пане Валерію Валерій
чали був просто зараз в нас ще є гості
ще є дуже багато людей з якими можемо
поспілкуватися просто зараз бачу Леоніда
ємця це народний депутат восьмого
скликання нині Він представляє
європейську Солідарність вже у київраді
пане леоніде Я вас вітаю із 30ю вас
річницею Незалежності пане леоніде ви
були при владі коли розпочиналася тільки
війна фактично при вас формувалися всі
ціі добробати військові які зараз
представлені на цьому марші що найбільше
найяскравіше згадуєте з тих
часів найяскравіше згадується статистика
Яку кожен ранок Ти просидався відкривав
телефони дивився скільки загиблих наших
солдат згадуються добровольчі рухи коли
люди які працюють викладачами
медиками просто працюють в магазинах
продавцями збиралися вдягали
цілували дружину цілували дітей і йшли
захищати рідну державу тому що ну крім
них більше нікому згадуються
їх листи звідти коли вони приїжджали і
розповідали з чим вони стикалися
згадуються розповіді людей які вживу
бачили смерть вижили в цьому і не
втратили при цьому бажання і оптимізм
захищати нашу країну жити в ній далі
виховувати тут дітей і віра те що у нас
все буде добре вони з такою вірою
приїжджали люди які готові були і вмерти
за нашу країну і вбивати за нашу країну
легко тут знаєте теорією займатися на
телеефірах розповідати які ви патріоти а
з'їздити туди подивитися в очі смерті
принести з собою перемогу над ворогами і
тоді ти розумієш що ця країна вона не
здасться незалежно від того хто б там
керував на яких посадах У нас є українці
які захистять нашу країну і настчать по
голові будь-якому ворогу вже другий рік
поспіль проходить отакий марш патріотів
ветеранів це і військові і їхні
родини Чи коли-небудь Ви думали що буде
о така саме згуртованість нашої держави
бо погодьтесь дуже багато зрад постійно
розповідають про якісь недоліки хтось
намагається розхитати ситуацію в країні
п'ята колона яка постійно протидіє а
потім наступає такий момент коли ти
бачиш що за тобою ціле військо чи
очікували Ви що буде ось Саме так Тим
паче на 30-ту річницю Я знав що так буде
я пройшов обидва майдани І такої
взаємної любові і взаємної підтримки як
на цих майданах ну не зустрінеш в
звичайному житті там людина йшла
спіткнулася і п'ять рук потягнулося
підтримати щоб людина не впала Я знав що
українці - це люди які здатні
згуртуватися заради спільної роботи і я
абсолютно кожного року на День
незалежності свята нашої України
переконують в тому наскільки нас
українців яких не подолати які мають
власну думку які вільні люди яких ніколи
не зроблять рабами наскільки нас багато
І сьогодні тут лише невеличка частина
тих хто доїхав але насправді ми дуже
сильна вільна незалежна країна і я вітаю
всіх українців з тим що ми сьогодні
святкуємо таку важко здобуту нашу
незалежність але ще не отримано до кінця
нашу свободу ми боролися будемо бороти
і ми переможемо ці люди ну це є просто
те чому Я впевнений чому ми переможемо
Дякую вам пане леонідо Леонід Ємець
народний депутат восьмого скликання і
депутат Київради був із нами друзі Як ви
бачите тут направду абсолютно Вся
Україна представлена різними регіонами і
бачимо надзвичайно велику кількість
різних стягів окрім стягів традиційних
класичних прапорів українських ще
Звичайно що кожен підрозділ добробати
всі вони представлені можна подивитися
на різні прапори
підписані ну тобто абсолютно вся історія
нашої понад семирічної війни Вона просто
зараз тут представлена в обличчях і в
іменах ще раз Я Хочу наголосити про те
наскільки абсолютно різного віку в нас
Наші герої дуже багато українців дуже
багато представників родин військових
прийшли підтримати наших героїв і
неймовірно тішишся коли Чуєш як всі
дякують як люди розуміють той героїчний
подвиг який був здійснений і який
продовжуть здійснювати наші українські
військові на фронті війна триває нічого
ще не полишено але коли ти бачиш що отак
Бачите я так встану і за моєю спиною
Ціла армія героїв і стає абсолютно
спокійно ти знаю що вони тебе захищають
що вони є вони з нами і звичайно що
надихають Що ми святкуємо не тільки 30
30-ту річницю нашої Незалежності А що ще
дуже багато все життя в нас попереду ну
і Я дуже сподіваюся що свого часу в нас
нас буде не просто парад до річниці А що
це буде парад Перемоги впевнена що це
буде дуже скоро друзі слідкуємо за тим
як продовжується марш ветеранів марш
патріотів наших героїв Ну і традиційно
будемо з вами виходити на
зв'язок
увага колгонни Брати по зброї справи
громад готовність 5 хвилин готовність 5
хвилин готові 5 минут я вам
сказавза
сямиць і ще наша свічка не згоріла
Ще наша молодість
принес
ацещеверта наше тіло
то Скажуть люди скаже
час Україно
на
серце твого
сина якти тобі
долі
перед вашими очима Що б ви розпитали
мушеників кого колись за щоро спинали
обніміте ж брати мої найменшого брата
Нехай Мати усміхнеться заплакана мати
благословить дітей своїх твердими руками
і діточок поцілує вольними устами І
забудеться срамотня давня яходина і
уживе добре слава слава
України України
Україну після
лечі
доі віне серце
го
сила
Україна
Україна та не я уже нормально не
взяла
Слава Україні героя слава Слава нації
ртва Україна сд усе Україна понад усе
Україна понад усе Путін
[музика]
лоля
давай
увага колона приготуватися до
[оплески]
руху
на майдан заходить коробка моків
Дніпропетровської області однієї з тих
які дали більше
на цю віну
привітаємо
б00є Дніпропетровська
область украї давайте згадаємо
кожно
[музика]
просто захиають Україну
більше
донечан дей Донецької області які
віддали життя за нашо
зле
Вані
вітаємо але доі ли доію доі багато
знаходиться збройних силах
ропа Давайте скажемо їм дякуємо
дякуємо
[музика]
дякуємо ми неодмінно повертимо дониць в
Україну з
10ти Да там ти Женя
віоля
по поше
на майдан виходить колона захисників
Житомирської області давайте привітаємо
[музика]
багатогадаємо так Ясь
стої
[музика]
постарайся на максимум поднять камеру
поднять Так а я ж видеть ничего не буду
хотя бы на уровне своей
голо чтобы ты колонну сейчас сделал
посмотрела в коло мы пойдём
вниз
обалден спасибо
[оплески]
[музика]
Слава Україні
колона рука
Руш
стй пропустите
[оплески]
сстору
[сміх]
[музика]
юрап
все
[музика]
нормально
[сміх]
[музика]
Так дякую Дякую друже триває наш
телевізійний ефір ми зараз знаходимося
на Майдані Незалежності ви бачите що
колони які рушили Хрещатиком зараз
повертають на гору вже до Михайлівської
площі з нами зараз перебуває депутат
Київської міської ради Тарас криворожко
Вітаю вас пане Тарасе Доброго дня свято
незалежностіі а вже ж а вже ж всіх зі
святом отже як Київ зустрічає 30тиріччя
незалежності ми бачимо насправді ну
чесно кажучи в Києві багато моїх друзів
які приїхали на святкування з інших міст
сказали що дуже мало державної символіки
дуже мало насправді нагадує про тирічний
ювілей на вашу думку чому столиця так
підготува саме до відзначення Я б не
сказав що мало державної символіки на
всіх будівлях фактично є державні
прапори і цим заопікується якраз місцева
Влада Я думаю що тут якраз в нас все в
цьому плані Гаразд але хотів би сказати
що в нас є якби дві сторони медалі є
свято яке відзначає держава і те яке
відзначають волонтери добровольці
ветерани АТО операція об'єднаних сил і
ті люди відповідно які зараз проходять
цим маршем патріотів де об'єдналися
навко до цього маршу і саме ця колона
величезна яка вже проходить більше
години і буде судячи з того хвоста який
я спостерігав в Дмитро університет буде
проходити ще не одну годину оце справжня
підтримка людей і ставлення до
Незалежності яке ми бачимо в столиці
України тому що треба усвідомлювати
незалежність суверенітет Свобода наші
українські
цінності європейський вибір усе це існує
тому і доти
поки ми за це боремося до поки ми це
відстоюємо тому що це не якась даність
це наша наші досягнення і наше майбутнє
на вашу думку в чому полягають головні
здобутки України в 30тирічний ювілей
Незалежності Що би ви відзначили в
якості найбільших перемог
України напевне та хвиля і підйом
патріотизму Те відчуття власної держави
країни яке Ми отримали на
жаль
вірніше всупереч здоровому глузду
напевне так нападу агресора але завдяки
тому
що ми отримали змогу об'єднатися і
отримати дійсно реальну незалежність
Саме зараз в ці роки і звичайно ім років
важких років ми боремося і на сході і на
півдні України тримаємо
кордон економічні здобутки хотілося
відзначити за попередні роки на жаль
зараз вони дещо нівелюються і шкода що
не держава не належним чином приділяє
увагу в тому числі місцевому
самоврядуванню Тому що ті досягнення
децентралізації вони зараз ну скажемо
так набагато зменшуються в рази ніж це
було раніше буквально -4 роки тому тому
нам треба будувати свою сильну армію
будувати і культурний розвиток який
знову ж таки отримав потужний імпульс за
останні роки від 16-17го року це і
українська музика з'явилася повноцінно і
книгодрукування і мова зазвучала так як
треба і оці досягнення вони дійсно є
фундаментом того що ми не здолані І що в
нас є те що нас нам дасть змогу
розвиватися і бути процвітаючою країною
в майбутньому на вашу думку а що
принципово відрізняє Україну
1991 року і Україну 2001 року в плані
людей в плані
самоусвідомлення Наскільки змінилася
загальна громадська думка Наскільки
змінилася суспільна свідомість Ну вона
насправді дуже сильно змінилася І якщо
ми мали такі осередки 91
році знаєте вибуху
патріотизму такої пасіонарності певних
груп людей які були достатньо сильними
потужними щоб їх почули і незважаючи на
те що як ви пригадуєте меншість була в
Верховній Раді тоді ще Радянської
України Саме народна рада на противагу
комуністам але саме це народне стм воно
дало змогу тоді отримати незалежність я
був в 90 році ще молодим студентом який
вступив до Київського університету і
Шевченка якраз почалася революція на
граніті і я тоді бачив як ми проходили і
кричали геть масола Кравчука на той
момент була було таке гасло з тим що
треба було зламати систему і зрозуміло
хто прислухався до цього хто не
прислухався і хто за яке місце в історії
зайняв і звичайно разюча різниця з тим
що ми маємо зараз все-таки в 91 році
такі колони проходили переважно
студентства молоді і інтелігенції Зараз
ми бачимо потужний суспільний
громадський рух який охоплює всі верстви
населення практично із усіх регіонів
України і оця хвиля патріотизму вона нам
показує що Україна перейшла знаєте це
таку критичну точку все ж таки
неповернення до тієї совковості до Якщо
хочете якоїсь реанімації авторитаризму
або якогось Радянського Союзу в
будь-якому вигляді і тим більше
диктатури Я думаю що зараз наше
українське суспільство цього точно не
дозволить дякую дякую пане Тарасе ще раз
вас зі святом але ми маємо ще одну
цікаву гостю я певен що ви знаєте
народна депутатка України вого скликання
Тетяна Доброго дня Вітаю всіх Вітаю всіх
зі Святом 30тиліття Незалежності це
насправді огого
прекрасно що особисто для тебе означає
свято тиріччя незале і яке свято ти
святкуєш день незалежності чи день
відновлення Незалежності
А ну для мене це таке от Як день
народження кожного року але це моя
країна та тобто я навіть не замислююсь
над тим скільки там років чи це ми
святкуємо Тільки 30 років Незалежності
чи відновлення чи таке інше Це просто то
той якраз день коли відчуваєш всю
сакральність ситуації хочу сказати що от
сьогодні для мене особливе свято от саме
зараз я зараз прийшла в колоні по
майдану я бачу Скільки прийшло людей
саме на марш захисників Вітчизни скільки
зараз знов таки як довго вже йде колона
захисників вітчизни це я вважаю
найголовніше чого ми досягли за 30 років
поясню Ну ми не будемо тут зараз
сперечатися що в принципі незалежність у
нас довгий час Була доволі
крихтка ми не будемо сперечатися що в
нас дуже серйозно зараз іде військова
агресія проти
нас кількість захисників вітчизни яка
наприклад зараз зібралася на Майдані -
це запорука нашої міцності є різні
критичні точки яка проходить держава в
своєму розвитку навіть неважливо Яка
влада неважливо яка навіть Влада зараз
важливо ці Захисники які якщо Критична
точка досягне піку вони вийдуть і не
дадуть історії відхилитися в іншу
сторони вони продовжуть далі шлях
Незалежності якж Це було під час
помаранчевого Майдану Як це було під час
Революції гідності як це почало було в
самий страшний рік рік агресії 14-й коли
і армії не було але оці Захисники
Вітчизни вони не дали повернути історі
від державності шлях державності
продовжиться але завжди Це було ну на
останньому подиху навіть оце 18-те число
на Майдані коли от палав Цей будинок
розпілок це було насправді на останньому
подиху 14-й рік це було на останньому
подиху але навіть о той Шлях який ми
зараз пройшли Я бачу що от наступні
критичні точки вже навіть не будуть на
цьому останньому подиху от нас багато
нас багато які в ту критичну точку не
дадуть повернути історію в бік
протилежний від державності А це дуже
важливо І ще одне дуже контроверсійне
питання напередодні святкування
нинішнього ювілею Як ти ставишся до ідеї
ухвалення Великого Державного Герба чи
на часі Це
сьогодні Ні я навіть тут скажу таку
думку можливо і варто піднімати питання
Великого державного грба можливо і варто
було а ле дискусія в суспільстві
публічне обговорення а не те що хтось
намалював якусь картинку до якої дуже
багато питань і її прийняли насправді
проголосували ті люди які не
заслуговували голосувати за великий
державний герб тому що в житті цієї
держави вони нічого не зробили корисного
і ніколи на захист цієї держави не
виходили Ну що ж дякую дякую Тетяна ще
раз тебе зі святом Незалежності
30тирічним юлеєм Слава Україні колеги
колеги от зараз ми
завершили нашу цю ефірну годину ми
спілкувалися з депутатом Київської
міської ради Тарасом криворучком і
Тетяно жрновол політикиня народна
депутатка України восьмого скликання
була гостем ми зараз транслюємо з
Майдану
Незалежності далі вам слово
колеги
повага за
[музика]
вони праве плеце
перед
[музика]
[сміх]
до колони вже долучився і п'ятий
президент України Петро Порошенко зараз
спробуємо з ним поспілкуватися Петро
олексійовичу Доброго дня зі святом вас
30річницю Петро олексійви що від пані
Марино І вас вітаю вітаю вас що ви
відчуваєте в 30і в 30 річницю дня
незалежності
ми відчуваємо гордість за Україну ми
відчуваємо гордість за український народ
і якщо згадати то нещодавно мене одним з
непровідних видань запитувало А хто є
найвидатнішим українським і моя
відповідь буде що це є Герой України
який мав честь як президент присвоювати
це звання це є герої Небесної Сотні це є
Герої які віддали своє життя і с
їх мами їх дружини їх Діти разом з нами
і це дуже важливо і це є волонтери це є
воїни це є добровольці це є те що
уособлює в моїй уяві Україну
непереборно як для яких Воля понад усе
яки готові битися за нашу незалежність
яка рухає країну в Європи подивиться яка
сила яка міць яка воля і точно наші
Перемоги переду я не маю в цьому жодного
сумніву ми звільнимо українську землю ми
звільнимо Донбас і Крим бо цей народ
перемогти неможливо ніякі не зсредини
країни ні ззовні не здатні зламати нас
це 100% Петро олексіч ви обіймаєте маму
видатного героя
українського мама Ярослава журавля про
якого дуже важко говорити вона сьогодні
з нами Ми дякуємо за вашого сина Я
розумію що для вас завжди ці дні із
сльозами на очах як і для нас Не тільки
мама і батько і батько і донька ми
обов'язково ще з ними поспілкуємося
Петро Олексійович досі не присвоєно
звання героя чому я думаю що сьогодні
у української влади була унікальний шанс
виправити цю помилку але я Хочу
наголосити що український народ давно
вже вважає журавля своїм героєм і для
цього ми не потребуємо ніяких реверансів
з боку влади
рано чи пізніше але я впевнений що
скоріше рано журевель отримає і офіційне
звання героям України так як він цим є
зараз і я просто хочу використати це для
того щоби подякувати батькам І
вибачитися перед дітьми за те що з цим
треба трохи почекати поки Влада зрозуміє
свої помилки але те що ми і тут
переможемо я не маю сумнівів бо важко
знайти людину яка більш
звання героя ніж журавель це правда чи
думали чи вірили би свого часу що ви
будете йти в колоні в потоці в ріках
патріотів і ветеранів які і попереду вас
і позаду що так багато В нас цих крутих
ного сумніву я в цьому переконався коли
в перші місяці війни Коли ми звільнювали
окупований Донбас 70% українців
намагалися допомогти фронту намагалися
допомогти країні намагалися допомогти
армі так буде і надалі ніхто патріотів
не зламає І сьогодні тут не тільки ми
подивитися на Марусю звіробій Який теж
намагалися зламати подивитися на її
посмішку хіба можна зламати таку
українську жінку я подивитися на Михайла
забродського героя України який
командувач був десантно-штурмових військ
Подивіться на наших ветеранів вони
великі
молодці Я хочу привітати всіх всіх хто
дивиться зараз телебачення хто дивиться
соціальні мережі хто дивиться пряму
трансляцію 30-ю річницею відновлення
Незалежності і з тим щоби ми сьогодні
подякували за це найнадійніший Гарант
нашого суверенітету збройні сили України
наших захисників які відродилися з 14-го
року і сьогодні є потужною силою яка
зламає хребет будь-якому агресору
включно з Путіним Ну а про Путіна вони
самі СКА казали під час репетиції параду
і я думаю що ще скажу успіху святом
Дякуємо вам і як обіцяли що ми будемо
вас сьогодні знайомити з різними і
маленькими героями теж не бійся ми на
секунду знаєте так буває що коли в
коробці з звільнюється місце то його
заповнює Нове покоління це донька того
самого героя про якого ми зараз згадуємо
Ярослава журавля морпіха який влітку
19-го року загинув Це його малесенька
донечка майже копія Ярослава правда Да
що сьогодні ти відчуваєш так багато
говорили про твого тата і його головний
подвиг - це те що він власне своїм
життям захищав День незалежності нашою з
тобою свободу і майбутнє які думки
сьогодні ти от я не знаю зранку відчула
чи почуття гордість про Україну і про
свого
батька як і ми всі
пишаємося Ти вже в другий рік поспіль у
коробці ста
портретом як ти гадаєш Чи бачить він нас
зараз так
так Чи розумієш ти що його подвиг - це
те що буде завжди жити в роках і роках і
ти маєш знати що ми надзвичайно
пишаємося твоїм татом Хоча ти ще така
крихітна і вже таке Випробування випало
тобі на долю але ми дуже дякуємо твоєму
та татові за те що він зробив ти
відчуваєш сьогодні тут з тобою Дідусь та
бабуся Да Так можливо ти щось би хотіла
сказати всім тим кого хто зараз дивиться
Хто можливо дещо в чомусь сумнівається
чи щось болить Можливо щось
[музика]
побажати скажи дуже важкі питання Я
задаю правда Я розумію Я тебе відпускаю
і дякую тобі до речі Просто зараз ми
можемо поспілкуватися як я вже і казала
і із принайні спробуємо із батьками
Ярослава журавля поспілкуватися тому що
це надзвичайно прикра і трагічна
ситуація що досі
загиблий герой журавель не отримав
звання героя України існує петиція Яку
мають підписати абсолютно всі наші
телеглядачі і звернути на це увагу
давайте зараз поспілкуємося із батьками
[музика]
Ярослава давай
як і обіцяла ми повернулися до вас пане
Сергію ми вас добре знаємо тому що Ви
часто виходите і на патріотичні акції Ви
виходите не тільки за свого сина а за
всіх синів України що ви відчуваєте у
30ту річницю
незалежності на даний час ці хвилини в
оцю годину коли я йду в оцій ході Як
назвав народ в оцій
коробки Я зараз іду по маленькій
території свж справжньої України
справжніми
українця
більшер я не
відчуваютіки тільки тому що я йду з
такими
людьми
за люди скіки
з тому я йду тому що
це це була моя мрія ну вірніше Мрія мого
сина приїхати на майдан обнять Володю
балука то що для для мого Ярослава
Володя Балук це це було просто все Ну
так як трапилось Воло не може зробити
Мій син значить моя родина повинна це
зробити коли під час
виборів ну
віковослужбовці авдіївської
промзони грузилися в автобус на вибори
Ярослав всьому в зводу попросив Хлопці
що ви робите Ну там вже ніхто не скривав
що хто йде за кого голосувати подумайте
що ви робите вам нужентой ло во ніхто
ніхто
цього тоді Ну багато хто цього не почув
вони почули тоді коли загинув Мій син
коли його бойовий побратим приїхав на
могилу став на коліна і сказав ярі
Пробач будь ласка що я тебе не послухав
що ми вибрали таку суку яка продала нашу
країну отаке Слава Україні я я зараз
такі хвилини в мене таке збудження я не
можу сказати Я просто украї живу в ці
хвилини гордістю за цю країну гордістю
за цей народ який зараз іде коли В тому
році я шов казали було 50 000 то зараз
це не 50
сгоднію
Я вдячний сім'ї порошенків хай там оті
хто злобний народ там хай що хоч думають
не просто вдячний цим людям людям які з
людяністю з усім до моєї родини мені не
важно буде місн Героєм України чи ні і
як батьків це вирішувати народу України
ну Я вдячний сім'ї Порошенко я вдячнийм
мільйонам людей які підтримують мою
сім'ю які пліч опліч Ідуть за з моєю
сім'єю під
судами переписки кругом просто я дуже
вдячний Дякую вам а ми Дякуємо вам за те
що ви виховали сина який є я впевнена
прикладом для багатьох і багатьох
українців Дякуємо вам Дякуємо друзі Ми
продовжуємо спілкуватися із всіма хто
зібрався зараз на марші ветеранів на
марші героїв Маш марші патріотів
виглядає купа людей які я прийшли ви
можете почути і побачити Да що така
безліч людей зібралася і для того аби
вітати наших військових наших героїв
просто українці які приїхали так само в
центр міста які дякують які аплодують Ну
і звичайно одразу хочу попередити що це
прямий ефір живий дуже важко
контролювати навіть коли ви чуєте відому
пісню про відомого кремлівського тирана
то зробіть нам сьогодні таку знижку все
стслюємо для вас тому коли ви це почуєте
давайте разом зробимо вигляд що ми не
вийшли за межі цензури просто зараз я
передам слово в студію для того аби
знайти ще героїв на
[музика]
включення
тактак дякую дякую Дякую друже Ще раз
вітаю з святом сьогодні
30тирічній Дата відновлення незалежності
України і ми маємо нашого чергового
гостя Мирослав Гай Ветеран російського
української війни з нами Вітаю росла
Вітаю всіх зі святом друзі Отже що
змінилося з психологічним настроєм
Українського війська українських
збройних сил починаючи від 2014 рокукіки
змінилася психологія українських
воїнів ну по-перше з 14-го
року Українські збройні сили
помінялися саме в першу чергу бо пішло
велика кількість патріотично
налаштованих активних розумних
освіідчених людей Добровольців і ну це
реально і учасники Революції гідності та
і просто люди які свідомі того що таке
незалежність що за неї треба боротися
готові за неї боротися
От
і збройні сили яких фактично до 14-го
року по-справжньому не існувало тому що
вони були розвалені ми це бачили в 14-му
році вони відчули шалену підтримку
народу України і оця підтримка вона
відчувається і досі ми бачимо що так от
у
нас був парад який організовувала Влада
було дуже багато людей але не менш
багато людей було на марші захисників і
зараз фактично ми бачимо що Разом зі
збройними силами з ветеранами крокують
волонтери крокують ветерани Нацгвардії
крокують медики крокують родини загиблих
всі йдуть ридають обнімаються тобто є
якесь єднання народу і ми бачимо що за
останні роки от 14-го року що змінилося
дуже просто це пояснити у нас зараз
волонтери збройні сили України і церква
є найбільш шанованими інституціями які
мають найбільший рейтинг довіри серед
усіх інституцій держави от що змінилося
наскільки важливо для України сьогодні
передати дух патріотизму щоб люди
розуміли справді що трицятиріччя
незалежності України є не просто датою
це є датою величезних здобутків в тому
числі і перемог Ми звикли говорити часто
вгуста про поразки але ж цих перемог
було дуже багато і не лише протягом цих
в цих 30 років але й в попередні роки
існування Української незалежної держави
наскільки сьогодні держава впоралася з
тим щоби донести цю інформацію про нашу
славну історію до наймолодшого покоління
українців ми знаєте ми бачимо еволюцію у
нас в 18-му році Україна була з якихось
причин позбавлена Перепрошую в 19-му
році Україна з якихось причин була
позбавлена параду на День незалежності
фактично
ну ми не мали таких святкувань У нас
були якісь концертики от в 20-му році ми
бачили що була спроба під
патріотизмом показати що патріотизм є у
вигляді якихось попвиконавців
якихось відомих гуртів і збройні сили
вони фактично були забуті до певної міри
ветерани були забуті цього разу ми
бачимо що влада розуміє що рейтинги
падають А українська патріотична
спільнота вже два роки поспіль це третій
рік Вже поспіль проводить свій парад
який не є державним це громадський захід
і цей захід збирає десятки тисяч людей
він збирає весь світ нації і зрозуміло
що під тиском під тиском патріотичної
частини суспільства і громадянського
суспільства наша влада вона трошки
починає мінятися в інший біг але все
одно ми бачимо
що ця еволюція вона штучна
це відбувається через просідання
рейтингів в першу чергу Вони тепер вже
точно розуміють що вони не можуть шукати
підтримки на проросійському
електоральному полі Вони намагаються
якимось чином всіляко показати що влада
зараз теж стала патріотичною Це добре Це
непогано Хай зпідпалки але вони
міняються але от ми сьогодні на параді
бачили нові зразки техніки їх же ж
насправді немає здебільшого у віськах
навді ті розробки які почали
розроблятися в 16му 17му 18му році Потім
були зупинені і тільки зараз ми до них
повертаємося тому Слава Богу що ця
еволюція влади відбувається ми маємо її
підтримувати просто питання в тому чи
Україна має час щоб гратися в такі
експерименти Я думаю що немає І от те що
сьогодні ми маємо окремий багатотисячний
волелюдний патріотичний марш який не є
провладним а Є окремим заходом Я думаю
що це велика великий дзвіночок владі про
те що треба пришвидшувати перехід на бік
добра на бік патріотичної частини
суспільства Дякую Мирослава за вашу
позицію Ще раз вітаю зі святом
відновлення залежнослав Гай був гостем
цієї ефірної години ми маємо ще одного
гостя одразу перейдемо до
[музика]
нього при
вод
Отже Що для вас 30тиріччя відновлення
незалежності України це не просто дата А
що 30тиріччя відновлення незалежності
України - це
насамперед консолідація усього
суспільства яку ми сьогодні
продемонстрували консолідація у вмінні
захищати країну відстоювати її інтереси
як в агресії проти Росії так і долаючи
внутрішні якісь суперечки і сьогоднішній
захід яскра показує що ми здатні до
об'єднання ми здатні Показати що ми
сильні ми
консолідовані ви сьогодні я не знаю чи
мали змогу дивитися за
військово-морським парадом який
відбувався в Одесі Це була звичайно дуже
захоплююче дійство це дуже вражаюче
наскільки Україна зараз наблизилася до
реалізації створення власних
військово-морських сил наскільки
концепція створення
відповідає м завданням я стоять на
Чорному морі е потрібно розуміти що це
процес не одного року і Враховуючи те що
багато років у нас по суті не було свого
флоту після анексії півострова то це
довготривалий процес але процес який
запущено тобто перші мбаки перші
кентаври Україна вже отримала і на
майбутнє потрібно тільки нарощувати щодо
концепції це в принципі питання до
фахівців які зараз цим займаються з того
що я знаю концепція є як така наскільки
Вона відповідає дійсності Будемо бачити
в майбутньому Наскільки я знаю ви ви
були одним з учасників
рятувально-пошукової операції Ярослава
журовля на вашу думку в цій
ситуації чого не було зроблено чому не
вдалося врятувати життя українського
воїна І на вашу думку чи буде проведена
все ж таки справедливе розслідування яке
назве всі прізвища ції
історії потрібно розуміти що
найголовніша скоріш за все проблема - це
те що Немає чіткого алгоритму дій в
подібних ситуаціях тобто конкретна Та
ситуація показала бездіяльність вищого
командування бездіяльність командування
батальйону але в основному знову ж таки
це Через те що не було нормального
алгоритму як Хто повинен
працювати
вібиі наої
заявили що беруть ц ситуацію під власний
контроль м самим влаштувавши
певну Скажімо так
незрозумілість тому що коли президент
заявляє що він бере якусь певну ситуацію
під власний контроль то вже суспільство
очікує відповіді коли відповіді як такої
немає дні спливають зрозуміло що на жаль
на жаль Ярослав загинув А ми маємо
нерозв'язану ситуацію з приводу дбр чи
розслідує він вони чи розслідують вони
нормальну цю
ситуацію я там не працюю але як показує
практика подібних розслідувань вони
затягуються на довгі роки а винуватці
так і не покарані Саме через те що там
задіяні інтереси досить високих
посадовців Ну що ж дякую вам за ваші
коментарі Ще раз вітаю вас зі святом
незалежності України і слава Україні
колеги на цьому наше включення в цій
ефірній годині завершилося тож
продовжуємоважно спостерігати за всіма
подіями у прямому ефірі вам
[музика]
слово
Слава
[музика]
Україні Слава
Нації
Україна збройним силам України тричі
слава слава слава добровольцям України
[музика]
трич якраз Олександре ти щоно згадував
справді про те що ми отримали
фантастичне гасло Слава Україні Героям
слава і це саме ті слова які сьогодні у
центрі Києва можна на частішей чути
причому вигукують їх прості люди тому що
дуже добре розуміють що сьогодні вони
побачили як виглядають всі ті люди не
всі але велика частина тих хто ось вже
понад см років в кожному із нас в
кожному куточку України захищає тому
бачичи кожного героя відповідно їм
кричать слова Слава безкінечний поток
людей який сьогодні прийшов підтримати
наших героїв і така сама ріка патріотів
надзвичайних синів та доньок України
сьогодні йде цим маршем патріотів ви
можете побачити що якраз не так далеко
від нас і знаходяться навіть не лише
Герої і військові які були на фронті але
які власне кривали дуже складними
операціями які відповідали за
згуртованість нашого війська це я вам
так вже натякаю на Михайла заброцького
який просто зараз тут з нами знаходиться
пане Михайло Я вас вітаю Доброго дня із
30ю вас річницею Незалежності ви не
просто народний депутат і не просто
військовий ви людина яка від першого дня
були на фронті просто зараз Святкуючи
30ту річницю незалежності ваші почуття і
емоції почуття і емоції мабуть ті ж самі
які були в 14-му році
е можливо менш патетичні але по суті
своєй вони залишились незмінними це
свято нашої самостійності це святом
нашого вибору зце святом нашого Святого
права жити так як вирішили Ми і
забезпечити таке життя своїм дітям
онукам і всім нащадкам без перебільшення
я можу сказати що тут сьогодні у
коробках і в цьому потоці героїв і
ветеранів війни дуже велика кількість
людей ваших побратимів з якими ви були
особисто на фронті Розкажіть що це за
люди і чим вони мотивувалися коли йшли
захищати
нас це дуже різні категорії людей
починаючи від професійних військових ті
хто прийшов за мобілізацією добровольців
всім була Фронтова дорога люди різних
військових спеціальностей різних фасад
різних звань але всіх об'єднує лише одне
це гостре відчуття свого громадянського
обов'язку і розуміння чітке те що В
скрутний час коли країна потребує твоєї
допомоги і навіть твоїх жертв потрібно
ці жертви приносити тому що інакше ми не
будемо мати право називатися державою
інакше Ворог буде нас зневажати і
рахувати що Україна - це так і
залишається як колись було чиєюсь
територією або провінцією або
федеральним округом для того щоб цього
не допустити люди зовсім різних
категорій різних вікових груп і навіть
різних професій і політичних вподобань
стають до строю беруть до рук зброю для
того щоб захистити свою батьківщину
Дякую яка вона наша сьогоднішня армія як
вона виглядає тому що ворог нещодавно
нагадав про те що він неподалік від нас
і про те що він все ще хоче загарбити
нашу незалежність То наскільки наша
армія готова дати йому по зубам На жаль
противник майже регулярно нагадує про те
що він стоїть біля наших кордонів
продовжується так зване перемир'я на
лінії зіткнення але час від часу ми
чуємо новини про чергові втрати серед
нашого особового складу але в будь-якому
випадку той стан збройних сил який
дякуючи зусиллям керівництва держави і
народу до якого стану вони були
приведені протягом останніх п'яти років
не можна навіть порівнювати з тим що ми
починали в далекому вже
2014 Дякую вам пане михайле і завжди
кажу що в нас є багато фронтів на яких
треба захищати нашу незалежність і і
політична і парламентський фронт Він
такий самий активний Микола Княжицький
сьогодні теж відвідав оцей величезний
марш патріотів пане Миколо Я вас вітаю і
вітаю з 30ю річницею ви були свідком
багатьох подій багатьох революцій в
нашій країні чи вірили Ви що на 30-ту
річницю все буде виглядати так і ми
нарешті побачимо як виглядають патріоти
і Захисники нашої держави ой Мені дуже
шкода що до цієї 30-ї річниці стільки
людей поклало своє життя за цю
незалежність і багато то тут іде х
справжніх героїв я не вірив що на чолі
країни буде людина настільки далека від
цієї країни кажу вам щиро і я вірв в дух
людей який я зараз бачу і відчуваю
величезну відповідальність Перед кожним
з тих хто тут іде нам ще дуже багато
зробити сьогодні хочу вас запитати і про
певну несправедливість тому що ми знаємо
що от всі ці Герої які зараз йдуть наші
ветерани наші військові Вони все ж таки
держава заборгувала їм дуже багато чого
це і виплати і підтри
зробити так коже геройв що державаму
заплатила за йго подвиг і те що він
зробив ви знаєте в країнах які воюють
люди військові - це еліта нації це люди
які отримують будинки квартири
забезпечене житло а найголовніше право
керувати країною тому що саме такі люди
Михайло Забродський який йде зараз коло
мене Я пишаюся що я йду коло нього тому
щоце справді великий державник і Патріот
який пройшов
ці люди звичайно нас недооцінені тому що
на якомусь етапі люди подумали що можуть
бути інші цінності Але я вірю і бачу що
люди вже повертаються до справжніх
цінностей і ми маємо віддати борг
кожному хто тутде в військовій формі
Дякую вам пане Миколо Микола княжецький
щойно з нами спілкувався я б взагалі
сказала що в нас знаєте така патріотична
перекличка От Можна сказати що хто
сьогодні не з нами то проти нас а ми
знаємо що тут більша частина без
перебільшення України з усіх регіонів з
усіх куточків і я знаю з ким ще можна
власне цю пере кличку зробити тому що
героїв і патріотів сьогодні достатньо от
бачу є наприклад і Пані Сюмар і пан
Парубій Пані Вікторія що сьогодні ви
відчуваєте під час 30-ї річниці
Незалежності
А ви знаєте величезна гордість - це 90%
і трохи сорому це 10 без нього якось
ніяк в нас не виходить гордість
насправді найперше за ось цю ходу тому
що Ну от таке враження що це та Україна
яка народжена після 14-го року о ці люди
які від справжності яких я просто
сьогодні плакала коли ми дивилися це і
це діти і їхні мами жіночі батальйони і
госпітальєри і звичайно учасники бойових
дій А ну неймовірні відчуття І знаєте
гордість За Україну за те що ми
змінились так насправді з того 14-го
року що в нас так багато перемог за нами
що ми змогли відстояти свою землю і
збудувати ту армію якою сьогодні А всі
ну пишаються очевидно А дехто піариться
хоча мало стосунку маю до її побудови
об'єктивно а оті трошки сорму знаєте
було за те що щоб зайти на парад треба
було більше години там вистояти в
страшенних якихось штовханині і мені
було дуже соромно перед дідусем який
привів свого Онука тягнув його так гарно
в
вишиванку розказував йому так багато про
військо але просто не не зміг достояти
він забрав дитину і повів її просто
звідте І за це було соромно от за це
було соромно було соромно за УДО яке
пропускало одну людину за хвилину хоча
Очевидно в цьому не було потреби це було
штучне обмеження Я дуже добре розумію що
Знаєте тут є декілька тисяч людей
декілька тисяч людей на параді а
дивляться це мільйони і от ну Влада
вирішила пропацювати на картинку на
гарну телекартинку забувши про те що ці
тисячі людей ці тисячі українських
патріотів які дуже багато доклалися щоби
армія була щоби військо було щоби
Україна була захищена люди віддавали
останнє а багато з їхніх рідних віддали
своє життя тому от за це був сором Але
тим не менш нас більше Дякую вам Пане
Андрію ми проходимо дуже символічне
місце Вам не здається дуже багато
українців вважає що саме оці місця ці
точки цей центр Києва це і була
переломна мить в державотворенні і
відстоюванні Незалежності я натякаю
звичайно на 13й-14-й рік що ви
відчуваєте коли тут проходите в 30
річницю незалежності велику гордість
відчуваю бо тих 30 років це не просто
незалежність це боротьба за незалежність
яка мала різні етапи але я цілковито з
вами згоден напевно вирішальний етап був
в 14му році тут на Майдані Незалежності
коли визначалося питання чи Україна буде
самостійною незалежною державою чи знову
стане колонією Росії і власне
український дух українських громадян
добровольців бо добровольці тут
починались самооборони Майдану на
Майдані вони змогли переламати намагання
ноковича його банди кліки повернути
Україну в стан колонії і З того часу я
вважаю що наша боротьба проти Росії це
переможна боротьба яка продемонструвала
що українці завдяки загальному духу і
воїнів і добровольців можуть протистояти
найбільш одні з найбільш потужних армії
світу і коли сьогодні вони йдуть по
Хрещатику це викликає гордість це
викликає повагу За Україну за українців
і за наше
майбутнє підписуємося під кожним словом
справді те що каже Андрій Парубій коли
ти відчуваєш надзвичайно гордисть за те
що ти бачиш єднання суспільства єднання
народу коли говорть про те що Ми різні з
різними поглядами чи відстоїмо якісь
різні табори ні абсолютно всі за одне за
незалежність нашої держави сьогодні
абсолютно всі з різних куточків України
виказують свою не надзвичайну повагу
українським військовим ви можете
побачити як Багато наших військових
патріотів колони які годинами йдуть
містом Києва завжди готові встати знову
на шлях Незалежності і захисту нашої
країни тож друзі нам є чим пишатися Ну і
власне традиційно ми будемо вам
абсолютно все і всіх показувати от я
думаю що на цих словах власне можна і
завершувати тимчасово на вулицю Героїв
Небесної Сотні кілька кроків назад будь
ласка
Дякуємо Слава
Україні
нації
[музика]
українасе
українае збройним силам України тричі
слава
увага колона для проходження алею небес
на істотні
[музика]
головніборозяти
про
[музика]
ковиer
магра колона для проходження Олею
Небесної Сотні головні обори зняти
прапори
кивети
загиблим Героям Небесної Сотні
тричі слава слава
слава герої не вмирають Герої не
вмирають Герої не вмирають Герої не
вмирають Герої не
вмирають прапори які піднімаються на
Небесної Сотні
схилити головні убори
зняти Героям Небесної СОТ
ричі слава слава слава
слава герої не вмирають
Герої не вмирають Герої не вмирають
Герої не вмирають Герої не
вбирають увага під ноги на Небесної
Сотні після мосту баларди дивіться будь
ласка під ноги обережно дивіться будь
ласка під
ноги
[музика]
колона
проходячи героями Небесної Сотні прапори
схилити головні убори зняти
давай давай давай
давай ні ні Бе не
вртує
заходячи на вулицю Героїв Небесної Сотні
колонна прапори схилити головні убори
зняти
замикаю
Герої не
вмирають Герої не вмирають
вмирають абсолютно абсолютно вітаю друже
Ще раз дякую і справді Валерій прозапас
депутат рікоїміра міської ради міської
ради а вже ж ветеран
російськоїукраїнської війни Отже пане
Валерію Що для вас означає 30тиріччя
відновлення незалежності України який
найбільший історичний урок Ну звичайно
на наше покоління просто випала така
честь побачити як відновилася українська
держава і нашому ж поколінню випала
місія все ж таки закінчити цей процес і
перестати вже бути улусом Москви а стати
по-справжньому незалежною державою і
вибороти майбутнє для наших дітей для
нащадків в єдиній європейській родині І
я вважаю що от сьогоднішнє свято та
кількість людей яка прийшла на це свято
ті події і ті Заходи які відбуваються не
тільки в Києві А в інших містах України
вказують на те що нам це
вдасться на вашу думку що принципово
змінилося в психології українських
збройних сил військовослужбовців у
украни від 2014 року ну оскільки я
потрапив у другу хвилю мобілізації то на
моїх очах збройні сили просто змінилася
кардинально тому що армія Буквально за
лічені
місяці вже стала
спроможною відбивати пряму російську
агресію і саме через те Москва Кремль
Путін були змушені вводити свої
безпосередньо регулярні
частини після всіх цих подій
Це була основна мрія нашої грослава
положити квіти на майдан на вулиці
Героїв тоді ще не була вона вулиця де
загинули де загинула Небесна со друга
Мрія мого сина була кріпко і міцно
обняти Володю балуха ну це довелось так
же зробити мені тому що мого сина не
було останніє слова Коли ми говорили за
волод він сказав бачи Володя дома я хоть
трошки поміг його освободити тому що
агеєго міняли десь в якусь строчку попав
і
Володя я всіх Вітаю моя родина моя
родина Вітаю всіх з днем
незалежності бажає всім здоров'я
успіхів всього самого
найкращого для тих хто дуже не любить
Україну я скажу
просто читайте у нас на весь район один
плакат наші Перемоги поперед читайте
частіше ці плакати
бібор і думайте головою А дійте серце
Слава Україні Героям слава Пробачте що і
ми хочемо звернутися до влади з вимогою
відновлення справедливості і присво
герою України народному герою Ярославу
журавлю звання героя України ми немає
причин
відтягування смиктування тут немає
політики це шанування справжніх героїв
України таких як Ярослав журовелі це не
просто данина поваги його батькам А це
позиція мільйонів українців не треба йти
проти народу дякую всіх з днем
незалежності політолог наш колега Сергій
Таран Сергію Вітаю Вітаю вас зі святом
отже отже днями в Києві точніше вчора в
Києві відбувався
черговий етап боротьби України за Крим
було заснована кримську платформу
президент України обіцяє що ми зараз
будемо реалізовувати нову стратегію
стосовно деокупації
Криму Як ви бачите шлях цієї деокупації
і чи допоможе в цьому Кримська платформа
насамперед для цього потрібна дуже
професійна зовнішня політика яка би не
знімала з порядку денного Україну і
особливо Криму будьде де відбуваються
якісь важливі саміти якісь важливі
геополітичні зустрічі і на превеликий
жаль за останні два роки ми цього не
побачили ми бачимо що зараз є інші
пріоритети а Україна якщо і з'являється
то навіть не завжди в хорошому контексті
Ну звісно якщо ми псуємо нашу співпрацю
з нашими партнерами через справу
вагнеріців чи через брак реформ в
Україні якій у нас за два роки то звісно
воно так і стається але дуже важливо
розуміти що в сучасному світі де кожна
країна воює за себе важливо мати
професійну українську дипломатію яка
доводить нашим партнерам світовим
лідерам в тому що підтримка України це в
їхніх інтересах для цього треба мати
дипломатичні здатності дипломатичний
талант і дуже гарно працювати з з тим
щоби Україна була в пріоритеті
зовнішньої політики от зокрема по Криму
Ну добре Звісно що відбулася Кримська
платформа безперечно важлива але
хотілося б щоб після цієї платформи Ми
почули щось конкретне Ну наприклад про
те що країни які входять до Кримської
платформи мають намір і оголошують
додаткові санкції щодо Російської
Федерації або наприклад країни які
входять до Кримської платформи спільно
будуть моніторити порушення прав людини
на території Криму деє Росія з тим щоби
ті кейси витягувати в міжнародні сди і
тиснути Таким чином на Росію хотілося б
почути заходи підтримки української
безпеки зокрема в чорноморському регіоні
от цієї конкретики на жаль не вистачає
ні під час Кримської платформи ні
взагалі впродовж останніх двох років
тому що на превеликий жаль у нас в
останні роки не є професійна дипломатія
але те що так багато людей підтримують
той курс який у нас був оголошений в
14-му році той курс який закріплений був
Конституції є дуже серйозна надія що ці
всі негаразди будуть тимчасовими і на
наступне покоління політиків яке прийде
на зміну цим буде займатися професійно
зовнішньою політикою як це було в часи
п'ятого президента Порошенка і Крим буде
український швидше ніж ми думаємо вже за
тиждень відбуватиметься надзвичайно
важливий візит перший офіційний візит
діючого президента Володимира
Зеленського до Сполучених Штатів Америки
де він зустрінеться із президентом США
Джо байденом а також іншими
американськими
високопосадовцями надзвичайно важливо що
цей візит відбувається в контексті
святкування 30 Рі чниці незалежності
України на ваш погляд як
трансформувалося
українсько-американське партнерство за
30 років і в якій точці цього
партнерства знаходимось Зараз ми найвища
точка цього партнерства чи можливо варто
чекати що далі буде ще краще найвища
точка партнерства була з 14-го по 19-го
року коли Сполучені Штати були лідером
світової підтримки України коли з
ініціативи Сполучених Штатів світ
оголошував санкції щодо Російської
Федерації і коли сполучені Штати
надавали нам летальну зброю пам'ятаєте
джевеліни ніхто не вірив що це можливо
але надали і це була був пік відносин
між сполученими штатами України на
превеликий жаль зараз не так тому що ми
бачимо що дуже багато скандалів багато
неприємних скандалів ну навіть Я не знаю
такої країни де б наприклад проти
нинішнього президента Сполучених Штатів
байдена інший президент намагався
порушити кримінальною справу де він був
бігурантом це є країна Україна тому
після таких речей наші відносини Напа і
зараз вони тримаються великою мірою
завдяки тому що Сполучені Штати
розглядають
центральноєвропейський регіон як сферу
їхніх інтересів тому що вони розуміють
що підтримуючи країни які належать до
центральної Східної Європи підтримуючи
Україну Сполучені Штати захищають
безпеку всієї Європи тому вони нас
підтримують але ця підтримка зараз
зовсім не така як вона могла би бути Я
щиро вірю що Ну українська влада має
нарешті покращити відносини між
сполученими штатами і Україною і я щиро
бажаю президенту зеленському успіху
Вашингтоні щоб в нього візит був вдалий
просто Це дуже важко для нього це не
зовсім його парафія але я сподіваюся що
завдяки тому що Президент Зеленський
хоча би Побачить і тиск суспільства і
побачить що відбувається сьогодні на
вулицях і зрозуміє які справжні
пріоритети України це Може хоча би дасть
йому можливість тримати правильну
риторику під час зустрічі з байденом Я
не вірю про те що ми повіримося на пік
наших відносин але хоча би хоча б що у
нас були нормальні природні відносини це
якщо хоча би сталося то це вже буде як
для Зеленського успіхом його візиту до
Вашингтону українська дипломатія за 30
років незалежності України цей шлях ви
вважаєте ну скажем героїчним можна
сказати що це був героїчний легендарний
шлях української дипломатії зрозуміло що
були помилки але в цілому як ви оцінюєте
років України нашого представлення На
світовій арені я думаю треба розбивати
на два два етапи знаєте от до 14-го року
це був етап без позавекторної або
безвекторної як Я називаю зовнішньої
політики Коли Україна не могла сказати
партнерам куди вона йде час від часу
вона казала що вона йде в Європу час від
часу вона казала що вона іде до Росії
реформ якихось особливих не відбувалося
якихось змін не відбувалося І Оце така
аморфна зовнішня політика призвела до
того що Україна в 14-му році на початку
опинилася самнасам з російською агресією
і тільки завдяки тому що Україна 14-го
року визначила зі своїм цивілізаційним
вибором зі своїм вектором у зовнішній
політиці Це дало нам суб'єктність про
Україну почали говорити окремо від Росії
вже ніхто в світі після 14-го року не
плутає Україно і Росії а до того плутали
вже ніхто після 14го року не буде
говорити що українці мало зробили для
того щоби стати частиною європейської
цивілізації і безвіз наприклад це дуже
гарне визнання цих прагнень українців
тому з 14-го року з'явилось вікно
можливостей для української дипломатії
зараз треба щоб ми не втра не втрачали
цю можливість і дуже важливо щоби Влада
розуміла що іншого вибору ніж активна
політика України ніж європейська
політика України ніж політика на вступ
України до ЄС до НАТО іншої альтернативи
для України просто немає І от зараз ми з
вами знаходимося на алеї героївнібесної
сотні які своїм життям заплатили за це
щоб цей вибір був для України остаточним
тому хотілося б щоби на вулиці банковій
яка Теж недалеко це розуміли знали і
підтримували той курс який українці
вибрали в 2014 році Ну що ж дякую пане
Сергію Ще раз вітаю вас зі Святом
віддолення Незалежності України Сергій
Таран депутат Київської міської ради а
також політичний експерт був гостем цієї
ефірної години я Тарас
Березовець продовжую стежити за всіма
подіями надзвичайно пильна так само як
це роблять наші журналісти і
кореспонденти по всій Україні студія вам
слово
[музика]
Україні
славаці
Україна Україна
[музика]
Слава
Україні Слава
Нації
Україна все Україна
понас Україна
пона що можу сказати дуже важко говорити
в цьому наторпі все через те що
надзвичайно велика кількість голосів які
сьогодні гомуном лунають всіма
центральними вулицями тому що тут
відбувається перекличка всіх героїв
лунає вже традиційне українське гасло
Слава Україні Героям слава Ну і сьогодні
це надзвичайно приємно робити особливо
коли ти бачиш що поєднуються дві стихії
це військові наші ветерани Ну і це
власне суспільство це українці Які які
сьогодні прийшли і підтримати наших
героїв Ну і звичайно що тут є
представники абсолютно різних подій
нашої незалежної України наприклад ті
які особисто на собі відчули не лише те
Як це жити під час війни не лише те як
це будети на фронті але ще й як це коли
ти стаєш бранцем Кремля власне Отак я
натякаю на ахтема чийгози який так само
сьогодні бере участь в цьому марші
патріотів пане чайгозие я вас вітаю і
вітаю з 30ю річницею Незалежності Що для
вас це
свято це свято для мене особисто це
[музика]
от визначе визначення України що вона
держава і те що
ми ми доводили це сотнями
років і сьогодні я от пишався стояв і
бачив нашу а
наших громадян і таке відчуття що ми
всі єдини а Влада вона окрема
це це саме
таке як кажу
ложка докця
да тому що ну як
так таке свято ільки крові за це свято
Да проліто і далі люди рбнуть і
борються
але люди
бачуть ветерани бачуть що є нам намір
одних окремо інших окремо владою діліти
оце не не
можна але так пишаюсь
і От коли ми іду і
кричать Крим Україна я я от
вірю Ми всі будемо ви визволяти Як ви Як
ви думаєте чи чують сьогодні Голос
патріотів наше гасло Слава Україні гером
Слава вашому рідному Криму якого нам так
сильно бракує і дуже б хотілося б аби
30ту річницю незалежності ми теж і з ним
святкували Ані
святкують і вони це демонструють і не
зважають так і не зважаю на те що там є
терор і
переслідування Вони кажуть Ми Україна
тому що є Ми всі тут і вони в нас вірять
Вони чекають нас і ми обов'язково в Крим
ввійдемо так от
пішком пішки будемо йти І каждий
сантиметр Криму будемо затверджувати за
Україною Хай почують нас в Криму Що
справді Ми дуже скоро повернемося Дякую
пане артеме бачу ще Андрія Полтаву це
українського блогера це вже і депутата
Полтавської облради Пане Андрію не
Ховайтесь від нас ну перш за все ми
вітаємо вас із 30ю річницею незалежності
України Що для вас це свято для мене Ну
знаєте 30 років тому Україна отримала
незалежність але от останні с років ми
її виборюємо заново тому що отримати і
завоювати незалежність це дві великі
різниці тому Ну принаймні за попередньої
влади ми боролися над тим щоб у нас була
сильна армія І сьогодні ми побачили яка
вона от стала і оті всі розмови що там
хтось її розікрав насправді ми можемо
подивитися як насправді це виглядає для
мене це Волонтери які йдуть з сідками
які вони плили для нашої армії і для
мене взагалі незалежність - це вільно
висловлювати свої слова вільно
пересуватися по с моїй країні щоб Отакі
автозаки не стояли не перегоро
шлях нашої колони і шлях нашої України
тому всіх з днем незалежності Слава
Україні Героям слава Пане Андрію ви
головний троль всього російського там де
за паребриком просто ікають коли вас
десь бачать от Скажіть ви бачите як
спекотно Да коли сьогодні почують що
багатотисячна колона ще й патріотичних і
сильних і мужніх співають той самий хідт
який ми зараз з вами не будемо співати
але що відбувається в
кмлі лалала оцей да саме саме цей хіт що
відбувається в Кремлі наскільки там
зараз палає Слухайте ну вони стартують
просто вони ж як свої Ракети запускають
знаєте Вони казали що американці будуть
запускати ракети за допомогою батутів а
свої ракети вони запускають за допомогою
нашої кричалки яку ми сьогодні кожні три
хвилини повторюємо щоб ніхто не забував
Хто насправді є хто хто ворог України і
хто за Україну Дякую Пане Андрію вітаємо
вас ще раз друзі Навіть не можу
спрогнозувати коли вся ця величезна хода
сьогоднішній марш патріотів наших героїв
ветеранів Може скінчитися тому що ще раз
і ще раз я нагадую сьогодні понад 60
коробок кількість людей навіть приблизно
порахувати дуже важко отак скромно
кажуть що це 70 000 Але ж ми розуміємо
що враховуючи ще й родичів які прийшли
підтримати своїх героїв українців які
просто так само прийшли і словами і
своєю присутністю відзначити наших
військових набагато бі сні без
перебільшення Вся Україна приїхала до
столиці до Києва під час цього маршу І
такої єдності нам дуже сильно бракувало
Тож давайте надихатися і разом зз вами
слідкувати за цим потоком наших
[музика]
героїв
срава
нації Україна
[музика]
Україна Україна
Путін збройним силам України тричі слава
слава
слава добровольцям України встричі слава
Ah
[музика]
[сміх]
А музыка У нас
здесь
[музика]
налеш
[сміх]
[музика]
хає і наілі пісню співає що тішить місу
я доброїз що втебе цір що тіло картують
і змічують дух Тиха роса зіб'ється трав
криком перед руз тут потомніч я тут
знайшов тещо жука леду здобу тебе
переміг сміли заі моя нахороба за те що
не впав за те що не ВГ Міли заський
хрест я ва пригода що буде триватимі
лим
сіклиськи
хрест
[музика]
ло трохи від заметілі скроні мої
пофарбують у сні я завдяги швемав наділі
в пам'ять твою закармую усіх друзів
своїх та ворогів кого любив і кого
вбивав Може чогось я не думів панеткубив
не програмна прогав іли за сітець моя
нагорота за те що не в мав за те що не
Ів Міли зажкийтрен ясва пригода що буде
тривати в мені цілий Сіт іли
[музика]
зажкийтре тим що загинули і тим що
пижили слово своє вдячно присвячую Хай
Боро зркає очима хижими нехай дарчить
мені нелячно тобі з корінням той не
зламається хто має серцень той не
зігнеться любов до матері найкраща
поранниця любов до вітчини і де я серся
теі креба ві такка по обраних летати на
груди АІ як твершення якися в бодати
ставали рабми якися в атати імалися
першими не відступитися
повака заногоярти руками БАМИ ристи у
світі багато прокой
зараз захоче лишається чистим
мили заі хрес моя ворона про те що небав
про те що не був
либачте
трава пригода що буде тривати в мені
цілий ік іли такките моя на дорода за те
що нев за те що неі
лив як ва привода що буде твати в мені
цілий вік
[музика]
ли
это конечно
[музика]
крел збились ми
великої години пожерж війни І полум я
гоі летав нас біль за долю України
простив нас гнів ілюдь на ворогів
йдав нас бі за долю України простив нас
Гнів і Люд за
[музика]
Воронів
ми йдемо в і переможним ходом тверді в
сні не звам ні мовкранів боплач не дав
нікому ще Свободи
борець той збуває свій болаш недав
нікому ще Свободи хто порестой здобває с
ухаї
зати герою зати герою тийди до сецмого
йди до сецного за твою ш за твою зло за
твої святій день за твої святій день
душами А тобі відротися
душами тобі відротися словою твоє
обвіритьсяє обвіриться страху нехай не
знаю я страху нехай не знаю не знаю що
таке
га і привіду привіду за сбо забо щоб
ілаш яі щоб вілащо яі щоб Віра моя була
граї щоб Віра моя була граї щом кафта
[музика]
втеліята
покуля слава
українікраїна
Україна велику суть для усіх єдину наш
гордий кли
народові несе вічизніть
ірний бе зупину нам Україна
Ще пона все в чиніть
рний без уну нам Україна
Ще по
[музика]
наце
веде наі герої в наших славах для нас
закон найвищий то наказ
Соборна
українська є держава Ода наі іяло
поправра Соборна
українська є
державана на
за на
[музика]
нас Героям
слава сер Рага Україна
Слава
уї гості нашо на Співочому полі у центрі
Києва на святковому дійстві з нагоди
30-ї річниці незалежності нашої держави
Слава
Україні здатні перемагати
це гасло Цього дня
незалежності впродовж віків українці
боролися за право на власну
державу незалежну соборну Україну і ось
Сьогодні ми святкуємо 30 років хтось
каже молода держава але я скажу що це 30
років відновлення української
державності А ми держава давня яка має
коріння у древніх віках Сьогодні ми
святкуємо нашу незалежність нашу Єдність
і нашу силу бути сучасною
самодостатньою незалежною Українською
Державою І так сьогодні маємо 30 років
наших новітніх
перемог і здавалось
як Софія Добре каже 30 років 30 років і
більше тисячі років ми давні ми давні як
світ ми давні як світ і дуже мені
хочеться то сказати коли ми вже
розвивалися як самостійна держава то на
нічних болотах ще жаби квакали і люди
там не ходили і ходили бурі ведмеді так
так тому сьогодні впродовж нашого
святкового дійства ми будемо згадувати
про віхи нашої Незалежності тому що нам
є чим пишатися однозначно
і я хочу представити ведучих ведучих
сьогоднішнього сьогоднішнього свята
сьогоднішнього концерту на сцені
сьогодні з вами Софія
Федина сяслав
Бойко друзі Дозвольте представити вам
сьогоднішню нашу
програму Сьогодні для вас танцюватиме
балет Життя неймовірний танцювальний
колектив який знають у всьому світі
сьогодні для вас гратиме просто
нереально крутий Танок на майдані Конго
сьогодні для вас гратимуть козак System
справжні козаки які показали що
український козацький може бути відомим
у всьому світі сьогодні для вас також
гратиме і співатиме легендарний Тарас
Чубай і сьогодні Також ми маємо прямі
включення із урочистої ходи яка
проходить центральними вулицями Києва
але також рухається до нас доєднатися до
нас тут на Співочому полі наші ветерани
наші захис
доброї волі волотери всі ті хто впродовж
багатьох років бореться за нашу
українську державу і допомагає нам усім
стримувати Московську
агресію марш патріотів він вже кілька
років як став доброю українською
традицією кожен кожен українець хоче
потрапити на цей марш і вістину це
багатотисячний народ народний марш яким
ми
показуємо хто ми є ми показуємо нашу
силу ми показуємо нашу міць ми показуємо
нашу єдність адже в одній колоні ідуть і
діючі військовослужбовці і ветерани
учасники російсько-української війни і
волонтери і ті які працювали як
волонтери були волонтерами від 14-го
року і до тепер вони ж
і в цій колонії і в тій колонії люди які
буквально один день працювали на
допомогу українському війську неважливо
скільки ти зробив для українського
війська важливо що ти зробив чи зробила
Важливо не залишати оронь Важливо не
бути тому що власне оця небайдужість то
і є наш з вами
патріотизм але сьогодні також дуже
важливо замислитися над тим А що таке
для кожного із нас
незалежність багато хто сьогодні любить
казати що Ой давайте ми не будемо про
минуле пам'ятати А будемо жити майбутнім
а хтось любить казати ой кака разница як
називається вулиця главне щоб Дорога
була зроблена а багато хто любить
сказати а багато хто любить казати що
нам неважливо давайте рухатися вперед а
я скажу що
для мене
особисто
незалежність - це наша
Свобода
незалежність - це право бути
вільними незалежність
це право на свій
вибір
незалежність - це право в своїй
українській державі говорити своєю
українською мовою ходити до своєї
Української церкви і розуміти що держава
Україна робить усе для своїх українських
громадян українська незалежність - це
також той феномен який стоїть на
століттях нашої боротьби і знову ж таки
коли ми говоримо про 30 років то ми
маємо згадати і Часи Київської Русі яка
в свій час була найбільшою імперією
Європи і і тоді з'явилося саме слово яке
дало назву нашій країні
україна коли ми говоримо про
незалежність ми згадуємо про козацьку
вольницю і першу у світі Конституцію
пилиппа Орлика козацька вольниця яка
прописувала і
гарантувала усі права і свободи своїм
громадянам боронила честь і гідність і
захищала усіх своїх
коли ми говоримо про незалежність ми
маємо згадати подвиги наших Січових
Стрільців української Галицької армії
української повстанської армії
української головної визвольної Ради
Української військової організації всіх
тих хто боролися проти усіх тоталітарних
систем саме за сучасну незалежну Україну
і ви знаєте тут мушу розказа казати
невеличкий анекдот Ви ж знаєте що
українська повстанча армія боролася
проти совітів проти польської окупації
проти німців а останній повстанець
вийшов з Криївки в 91 році як
проголосили незалежність України але
отут виявилося що якийсь повстанець
вийшов з Криївки буквально на днях
виходить і питає Ну що Вільна Україна
вільна йому Кажуть люди а де лінія
фронту питається повста ць та там на
Донеччині і Луганщині і тоді повстанець
із Західної України каже А нічогенько ми
так фронт просунули тому друзі Сьогодні
ми шановуємо і пам'ятаємо і заряджаємося
силою в усіх тих наших історичних віхах
які дали і наближали нам нашу омріяну
незалежність сьогодні українська держава
у нас є Чого не було попередніх борців
але сьогодні ми стоїмо перед шаленним
викликом і агресії Московської Федерації
і спроби затерти нашу державність і
спроби розказати що ми ніхто а звуть нас
ніяк Але я вірю дивлячись на наш
український народ а зокрена на наших
неймовірних захисників що усе це не
пройде що наша Україна була є і буде і
ще трошки спільним зусиллям ви ми
виборемо нашу українську перемогу ми
відкинемо далеко можна до пекла усіх
наших ворогів і зайт які посягали на
українську незалежність і суверенітет і
так я точно вірю що з Божого
благословіння ми будемо жити у нашій
рідній успішній процвітаючій Українській
державі
з Днем Незалежності
Україна вітаємо вас
українці ти згадала про
пекло Я тобі хочу сказати що пекло
мабуть не резинове а українські степи
вони безмежні я би сказала що московські
полярні там терени в Сибіру якраз
годяться краще тому що всякої нечисті
нам в наших степах не потрібно мати нашу
землю ми можемо запропонувати нашу землю
але ми запросимо їх
у якості
біодобрива хочете бути на нашій землі
будь ласка от український степ ми будемо
його розорювати будьте біодобривом на
наші
землі друзі добре Софійка сказала
щоми мусимо вибороти право бути
незалежними тому що ми стоїмо на кістках
тих хто боровся тисяч років до цього дня
Ми стоїмо під поглядами тих х
життям довів велику істину Україна понад
усе ми не маємо права
відступити Ми не маємо права зробити
крок назад Ми не маємо права Віддати ні
Донецьку ні Луганську область Ми не
маємо права профукати Крим Ми мусимо то
все повернути назад тому що то є наше
нам чужого не потрібно нам потрібно
тільки наше так чи ні так
ні-ні щось дуже слабо сказано так чи ні
так Ото я розумію коли я говорю то люди
якось так слабенько слабенько реагують
коли Софія фди Ну я розумію то є
практика то є вже практика в Софії
практики набагато більше як у мене
Софійка виходить на на сцену і люди
зразу оживляються і то є дуже добре
надзвичайно приємно бути з тобою тут на
цій сцені Ну і друзі ми анонсували що в
нас на сьогодні буде цікава мистецька
програма
і хочемо для вас анонсувати перший
колектив який танцюватиме для
вас розпочинаємо наш концерт і
запрошуємо на сцену балет Життя Я
впевнена що ви всіх їх бачили тому що
вони разом з Русланою принесли перемогу
нам добробаченні неймовірні хлопці
дівчата і які станцювали Дикі танці
популяризуючи культуру України цей
колектив зі своїми проектами об'їздив
понад 50 країн світу а цьогоріч дуже
символічно що балет життя святкує своїх
35 років танцюристи ніколи не залишалися
осторонь суспільно-політичних процесів в
Україні цей по схід концертні тури на
Схід активна у
гідності поїздки в зону АТО і всі їхні
проекти наповнені любов'ю вірою в
Україну тож вітайте балет Життя з
хореографічною композицією за
Україну
[музика]
[оплески]
am
[музика]
театр танцю
життя балет Життя в вашій області
активніше
друзі друзі зараз
на сцені
готується наступна команда
виступати я вам даю гарантію що ви їх
знаєте ви їх знаєте як мінімум через те
що я вже їх Сьогодні оголошував я
анонсував що вони сьогодні будуть на на
нашій сцені
виступати перед цим я хочу запросити все
шановне товариство яке десь ходить гуляє
бродить підходьте будь ласка ближче до
нашої сцени єдине що як я вже говорив
сектор жовтими лавками Е будь ласка Не
займайте тому що то є місця для
військових для ветеранів для для
інвалідів які ідуть в нашій колоні які
йдуть в Ну і як ви бачите вони абсолютно
розкішно крокує зараз центральними
вулицями Києва але я вже так розумію що
вийшли на фінішну пряму іти до нас сюди
до співочого поля знову ж таки це є
ветерани і військовослужбовці різних
бригад добровольці
волонтери ті люди доброї волі які всіма
своїми зусиллями допомагають армії
тримати оборону та й зрештою напевне
варто зараз зробити аплодисменти навіть
для самих себе тому що я не вірю що тут
є люди які коли-небудь не помагали армії
тому Давайте поплескаємо самі собі ми
цього вар тому що ми би ніколи не
зупинили Московську орду якби кожен із
нас не не змобілізувавши Усі сили не
допомагав українському
війську в нашій колонії ідуть Брати по
зброї це є нове нова формація нова
громадська організація про яку
розповість її голова про яку самі хлопці
будуть вам сьогодні розповідати Брати по
зброї це об'єднання ветеранів учасників
російсько-української війни також ідуть
активісти громадської організації справа
громад справа громад - це одна з тих
організацій яка активно дуже активно
допомагає фронту допомагає війську е не
просто словами а справжніми ділами я би
навіть сказав подвогамикладу Для
прикладу я хотіла би навести Напевно ви
всі чули що зараз надзвичайно
активізувалися московські снайпери і на
жаль більшість поранених і загиблих на
фронті - це від кулі снайпера саме тому
справа громад мобілізувавши усіх добрих
людей зробила можливим за закупку і
відправку на передову величезних
антиснайперських комплексів які сьогодні
закривають понад 30 км лінії
розмежування А це значить що наші
Захисники наші хлопці і дівчата
отримують
додатковий шанс на життя ось така наша
справа громад і коли свого часу я був на
сході з концертами я був також в 10тй
гірськоштурмовій бригаді І власне я я на
власні очі бачив ті комплекси Я бачив
той каскад
моніторів на яких видно фактично всю
лінію зітнення яку контролює 10та
бригада Тобто ми не живими очима
спостерігає ємо за ворогом А ми дивимося
за ворогом за допомогою камер і
буквально нещодавно якщо мене не
підводить пам'ять одну камеру Снайпер
російський збив І що сказав Петро
Олексійович Натомість ми купимо три Що
вже й було зроблено так є тобто наші
камери це такий собі специфічний Змій
Горинич одну рубаємо три три виростає
знову я взагалі можу сказати що
волонтерський рух в Україні є чимось
абсолю неймовірним тому що люди не
чекають люди не чекають розпоряджень а
просто дивляться Чого бракує що треба
зробити просто приходять і це роблять і
правда В 14-му році в певній мірі
волонтери підмінили собою державні
механізми на певний час допоки у нас був
президент Утікач І допоки держава
мобілізувалася на спільну координовану
працю з заради свого захисту і саме тоді
волонтерський рух він виявив отой
феномен українського народу об'єдналися
українці не тільки України а й всього
світу дякувати Богу мав можливість
подорожувати Європою також як музикант і
я постійно зустрічався з тими
волонтерськими ініціативними групами чи
то в Польщі чи то в Німеччині чи то в
Чехії чи то в країнах Балтії в Бельгії в
Люксембургу в Нідерландах всюди всюди
всюди всюди є українці які допомагали
яко волонтери є ті що організовували
збір допомоги є ті що безпосередньо
возили передавали і отой волонтерський
рух він об'єднав об'єднав нас усіх і дав
можливість сповна відчути нам що ми є
українцями і що ми мусимо просто
допомагати один одному Ми мусимо
триматися разом тому що Тільки в єдності
є наша сила ви зверніть увагу коли ворог
хоче нас роз'єднати він робить інфовкиди
Він робить різноманітні інфоприводи для
того аби виявити різні точки зору різні
думки і на найбільш таких радикальних
радикально різних поглядах ворог починає
акцентувати акцентувати увагу і десь
Воно призводить до сварок І оте поняття
єдності воно вже відходить десь на
другий план тому святослави Ти знаєш о
тут мені спало на думку що в такий
момент коли нас всі роз'єднують і
розказують яка Україна різна які ми всі
різні які в нас різні думки треба
пам'ятати заповіді Митрополита Андрея
Шептицького а він казав дуже просто усі
люди поділяються на дві групи ті що
люблять Україну і ті що її ненавидять
тому я впевнена що ті що люблять Україну
в будь-який момент всетаки змо можуть
знайти одне з одним спільну мову і разом
стати на захист України зрештою разом
святкувати незалежність України і разом
будувати успішне майбутнє української
держави
однозначно я пригадую Майдан і ви
пам'ятаєте Майдан Коли нам говорили що
схід і захід не може бути разом коли
говорили що Україна різна А коли
говорили що Ми не можемо знайти спільної
мови між собою Майдан показав абсолютну
протилежність нарикаді стояв гуцул з
Верховини і Шахтар з
єнакієва коли стояли хлопці з
Чернігівщини і фермери з Херсону оце
було абсолютне єднання це було абсолютне
єднання українців і це було справді
Класно Це було дуже тепло і власне оте
єднання ми мусимо продовжувати далі
навіть інколи переступаючи через своє я
ми мусимо в багатьох випадках питання
пріоритетності ми державу мусимо ставити
вище над собою тому що коли держава буде
в достатку коли держава буде в безпеці
тоді в достатку і в безпеці будемо всі
ми з вами і наші діти і наші
внуки Ну і поки зараз тут музиканти вже
підключаються знаєте хотілось би
нагадати дивлячись на цей неймовірний
марш постанську давню пісню яку казали
ніхто не буде співати ніхто не буде
слухати але ті заряджали на Перемоги
наших українських
повстанців вони сьогодні так само
допомагають нам святкувати і боротися за
Україну а я думаю ти теж цю пісню
знаєш ми йдем вперід над нами вітер ві є
і рідні нам вклоняються жита від радости
аж серце
мліє за волю смерть нам не
страшна від радости аж серце
страшна ми йдем вперід над нами сонце
сяє гармати б'ють здригається земля і
гордість грудьж
розпинає за волю смерть нам не
страшна і гордість грудяж
розпинає за волю смерть нам не страшна
ми йдем вперід над нами сонце світить
гармати б'ють здригається земля але ви
знаєте отут згадала як мо моя мама
казала І так зараз люблять казати хлопці
на передовій що То добре що нам за
смерть нам не страшна але все-таки не
нам треба вмирати за Українську Державу
А треба щоби гинули всі вороги які
припхаються на нашу землю а українцям
однозначно треба жити розвиватися любити
святкувати працювати але просто бути
щасливими своїй українській землі так І
тільки
так друзі команда яка
зараз комутується на сцені
а це є культова команда культовий гурт
родоначальники
родоначальники головні драйвери
українського хіп-хопу ви вже мабуть
здогадуєтесь про кого я правда Ану ще
раз
Конго А кажуть Конго чи кажуть
[музика]
у
майгонок танок Так
[музика]
звісно тисячі концертів про них власне
про них це тисячі концертів це більше 30
кліпів це багато платівок це нечисленні
альбоми це фільми про них це все про
один гурт
легенда легенда української сцени
команда яка вже більше 20 років турує
шлях українському хіп-хопу на сцені
України на сцені світовій Танок на
майдані Конго
[музика]
[оплески]
вітаємо
коцерга ми
ємо
патріотів
сеце скинув Перуна
стався Мені байдуже мені те все
[музика]
байдуже подивись наліво Подивись направо
Це твоя земля це твоя держава історія в
неї строката яскрава Слава Україні
Героям слава Спочатку не було ні птахів
ні риби і раптом стався великий вибух з
лися зірки і котики похтастці ко короче
все що треба людині для щастя колись на
цих землях жили трибільці вікенді квойка
то все ще напише А про кімерійців писав
ще Гомер не той що з мультика трохи
інший далі з'являються східні слов'яни
Поляни сіворяни та інші древляни
прийдуть вороженькі то б'ють супостата
нема супостата і туть брать на брата ще
апостол Андрій було як си подивить скаже
файне місто збудують на Дніпро кище
Хорив і сестра їхня либч начестьною
річка і станція метро не було інтернету
і радіостанцій нудились князі і шукали
задію в будь-якій незрозумілій ситуації
ходили походом куди на Візантію там вже
навчилися Господа боятися і співати у
церкві Боже прости тоді Володимир
Великий покаявся скинув Перуна і Руся
охрестив у кожного князя була своя фішка
Святослав Хоробрий воював до нку Ярослав
Мудрий писав мудрі книжки а мене мак
слухав маму і завжди нозив шатку все що
до того було єрунда бо тут навалилась
монгольська орда та робить сильнішим те
що не вбило вбився відважно король
Данило тільки в полі один не воїн звісно
і зростало потроху Литовське князівство
з одного боку пани польські з іншого
боку орда Московська прибри деж не
дружити зажурилась Україна що нічим
прожити аж тут вчайдушні як хижаки Люді
підняли шаблі козаки поки батько Ботан
не вступив у борв задружився з цареми і
споров фігню Та кров козацька вона не
для понту допуш Кармелюк залисняк гонда
за долю боролись народу бо Козацькому
роду нема переводу не тільки в шавлях і
гарматах сила пам'ятаймо друзі Петра
могилу відкрив академії щоб всіх навчати
Ох красиві та чаться Дівчата а хто
перший іпан у Європі ну григорй салич
Сковорода Пушкін ще не вмів говорити а
Іван Котляревський написав енаїду
подивись наліво подивись направоце твоя
земля це твоя держава історія внеї з
проката яскрава Слава Україні Героям
слава Танок на майдані Конго радий
вітати шановне панство з Днем
Незалежності
шановні
в принципі можна підходити
підходити ближче до ни тому що музика
то відривайте п'яточки від землі сідницю
від Стрільців
розслабляємося відпочиваємо
дітко у ре ло
одягає біла по Всім
допомагає біла по пісню
заспіває біла Вово Добре що у нас є біло
Вово що за країна коли нема героя той ту
не зазвичайся люди горосяляки від мене
люди полики ще роваки
дивопачакилі навколи мене ворогів Легіон
я Білий ангел на їх лі ліяна наркомани
всох мене злі срах не на всіх чей жах
неваітає він топа комувах чорний плач
під ним біли чимано яяку кіно як у кіно
крило одягає
Іва бобо Всім допомагає
Іва бобоу пісню заспіває
піва Бобу Добре що у нас є ііва Бобу
крок за кроком тепастп па Я читаю реп
кайма запащ гадом буду буде хі в нас все
добре Як там вас В нас за ворі вчора
перекили гас А ми зіграли дориві Доре та
покликали героя до
[музика]
себе на ко на машині репертуару в цей
трек
крилоягаєі всім
допомагаєівобо пісню
[музика]
заспіває Добре що у нас
є
[музика]
що ж це за чувак взагалі Леонід буряк ні
Павло зіфро ні Сергій лебро
сіркоропилив ні лікарой полить
чука
славакерчук
ні ней ній це людина пана нехце Старо
надять ком це супер Іва бобоул не крило
одягає Іва бобоул Всім
допомагає біва бобол пісню
заспіває біва бобол добри що у нас є
біла бобоу сило
одягає біла Бобу всім до домагає
ліва бо пісню
заспіває сліва Богу добре що у нас
[музика]
є і якщо ми так чи інакше всі зараз
Супергерої тому що в нас сьогодні свято
велике в українців в нас День
незалежності Дякуємо що ви тут і
хочеться щоб ми розуміли що Україна і є
наш головний супергерой тільки від вас
залежить Як ви зараз це прокажете
домовились Добре що в нас є
Україна
Україна разом
Україна всі почути Зараз саме
[музика]
украї
так ну голоси ми трошечки зсунули з
місця Ну в принципі ж всіже дорослі нам
всім сьогодні 30
років все
попереду нам вже все можна правильно так
от Якщо нам все можна то давайте зробимо
з вами спільну пісню до дня незалежності
про уїкого супергероя наш буде коплет
ваш приспів ми недарма перевіряли ваші
голоси особливо ваші я чув Так от
наступні пісні ми співаємо коплет
шановне панство співає приспів слова у
вас приблизно такі було Як би не було
все одно добро закохає зло Ви готові
заспівати Так ми селина на продамо ми
будемо ще ходити 30-40 років ви
готові оце вже
[музика]
краще не забувайте наш куплет
ж
приі у тритисячом царстві затриті від
земель двері печель ончуж позвітали
погані люди в гості завітали попалили
посварили короч погуляли вся розважалися
іді мало пов аж поки не з'явився Пало
Василь Я ще не вихадави де він був
раніше може собі спав поки паломвала
тишаже біля річки царапав др морди і тут
почує клається незнайомі морди а лорди
повтікали Вони завжди тікають відразу
забувають що про простих людей гупнувася
першого гупнувася другого гупнув
головного решта і тікач насогнав
останнього сплющив йому голову підібрав
мальберта і далі малювать вать-вать
Тепер ви І що там
[музика]
що
доби Ану там
[музика]
чніше а друга казочка про те як паціну
нацька закохався у аду премудру всіляко
залишався дарував їй будру а але вона
премудра за нього не йшла і попросуцій
Корі вастю далюш моруш Не міг би ти
друзяко сплавати туди і всяко різномодні
яскраво над природні рочуце імпортне
привези сюди батья кажу добреій Пап до
сонця тотиди всі понці дракони і ти і по
дорозі гади лохі і конокради всіляко
намагалися перетинати гуваловази гупав
їх усіх За людську любов за дитячий сніх
привіз ус красиве швидко живих і
намалювавчихто на веселя
і щоб там
що з
робить давай
[музика]
давай багато чого після того щей зні
було скріз васильчику одна хиля взло а
потім каже Шановні я бачу всі визловні а
я т в почу віни баш не ба гроші ваші не
ваші Я краще свато могучно про те яко
сеце було було і тепер тільки ви
що
[музика]
Ява ла
дравий там не
було якби не було все одно
добро закохаєм
що б там
не Як би не було все одну
думку закохає бу
[музика]
дякуємо дякуємо аж підскакуємо у вас
чудові голоси не стримуйтесь
зараз багато різної риторики щодо
ворогів доводиться чути що треба все ж
таки
якось по-новому до них ставитися ми
пропонуємо такий спосіб закохування
ворогів розуміючи що тут діти і дорослі
і зовсім дорослі ми пропонуємо такий
спосіб ми ж всі християни ми всі добрі
люди побачили ворога обійняли його і
тримаємо так довго поки ворог не
здохне ось такий спосіб закохання григів
пропонує гуртанок на майдані Конго
молода починаюча група з Харкова Дякуємо
[музика]
вам Україна
чемпіон
[музика]
ві повіідривати п'яточки від наступні
пісні теж потрібні ваші
[музика]
голоси ни свято шановні я вас вітаю
їграли тількищомо Китая чемпіони світу
жовто сині ртия порувала шаулі у
чвефіналі обіграли варуфу далі Аргентина
пішла у дуфу протестуто плакав а я ржав
ледверота не зламав Шева крутіші за
Тараса Кожен з нас за нього тягнув базу
коли він забилато показував звіт разом в
країні бувкоч далі Швидко всі ставали і
Тото тупі в окулярах узаді А як я джолин
мін кульпн гімн України заспівала група
корн ратижо я вам кажу Тиш ніколи не
пришу я з даю давай даюва даю пішо я вам
кажупішо ніколи не брешу пішо
ядаю
даю нарешті отримали хні це одна
щослиних наших Ремі їхали півроку нів
року на собаках Леді у сутнях пацани
ухалях виходимо на сцену ти моїволя шкоі
тобі чер Так хо всі космос буде А у
нашому Річі А я казав простого не всі
уте оди влаштували телевіз Та що це яке
себе Буся батоди моя бабуся та її
командануся та ти що я вам кажу татий що
ніколи не брешу татий що я здаю давай
Та ти що я вам кажу Та ти що ніколи не
пришу Та ти що Я даю
[оплески]
[музика]
давайй і відразу ія показав я Пізі бачу
прямоє до мене брні с попереду себе несе
свої дві октави хлопці сама із Полтави я
питав і всіх діч тобі запрошую до себе
набоч ми що що ж ми тами зні узялий
таксі поїхали до Ой летіли тики гуси
співали на сльози падали на вуси як
завжди у сівас спікали двіч а бранці 5
доларів по затиш я вам кажу затищо
ніколи не
пішо ядаю давайва
пішо я вам кажу пішо ніколи не
тию
[музика]
давайй та тишо я вам кажу тактишо ніколе
не врежу та
ішою давай
ю Так іщо я вам кажу так іщода нерешу
так іщо яю давай
[музика]
даю
дякуємо
друзі а ми вітаємо на Співочому полі
наших ветеранів ветеранів
російсько-української війни учасників
російсько-української війни добровольців
волонтерів людей доброї волі тих кому не
байдужа доля нашої з вами України з Днем
Незалежності вас всіх
[музика]
[оплески]
з нами є Брати по
зброї з нами є справа громад з нами є
Бог і правда і
ми разом до
перемоги і продовжується концерт танків
Танок на майдані Конго для
вас
[музика]
ці
зійшлися зима закінчилася рано
вранціноце коли у колі танець У такому
випадку я індіанець все Мене цікавить
все мене турбує якщо прислухатися я
трохичу я відчуваю
запас я повертаюся до лісу на корячи кла
Мені цікаво чи то дає багаті віри чи
гріє в зімку Ведмежа шкіра чого вони
лякалися чого чекали на що сподівалися
за то все ви мали як воно життя біля
віхма на кого полює та до що готує мама
мозок достатньо
інформаціїти як льоду
гранулими і крапле зими ростану тану
тану
танули як льоду крану Лили і втрапни зми
ростану тану видметі попрокатались
порлогах прийшла вос зняла облогу Ось я
дивлюся в небо ідмильшими очима що це за
прямо Що пропливають мимо мене діхають
всещо Де Коли Як моя видимельжа Лапа
якагу на шмак зв'язок втрачається ртина
млява Так це чи не так це лише моя
уява погляд тахи вертаюся додому Як вам
знаю що саме сюди дорога і як долають
свою меди пчас зимову чи розуміють що
невийти ни справо Бога якщо ти у повітрі
за кого в себе маєш звідки знаєш що в
тобі си про що ще мріяти коли розкриті
крила що ти відчуваєш що
відчуваєш
[музика]
А
стану тану
тану та
[музика]
ростану
тану
[музика]
сміх чудово наво якби цей слід говорити
міг я бусті спитати що із нами стане в
тих хто був раніше за усіх
зна чекає сигнал щоб почати але що хоче
Кати На що чекати мій мозок перебуває у
фрустрації недостатньо
інформації Та ви
як льоду
ранулими іраплю зими ростану тану тану
танули як льоду
грануми і крапли зли
[музика]
ста
[оплески]
дякуємо дякуємо дякуємо аж підскакуємо
наступна пісня
присвячується і тепер ми зможемо
випускати такі ракети які здатні летіти
значно далі ніж зараз І це має
стримувати нашого
во теж стає вразливи
[музика]
Ніко
не вдасться здолати Україну ми готові зі
зброє в руках захищати власну землю
боротися за кожен їй клаптик і Нікому її
віддавати не
збираємося Слава українському народу
Україні
Слава я використаю весь свій
дипломатичний досвід щоб забезпечити
підписання міжнародного договору який би
прийшов би на заміну Будапештського
[музика]
меморан вітаємо на нашому святковому
дійстві пятого президента України лідера
європейської солідарності Петра
Порошенка та пані Марину
[музика]
[оплески]
Порошенко дорогі друзі Ви
найкращі у вас відбувся неймовірний марш
коли десятки тисяч людей пройшли по
Києву для того щоби
продемонструвати У нас є велика
вдячність велика вдячність тому я
нещодавно давав інтерв'ю одному відомому
виданню і мене запитали Скажіть будь
ласка А хто найбільш достойні українці
Хто за всю історію в вашій уяві відіграв
найбільшу роль встановленні і
забезпеченні незалежності нашої держави
моя відповідь була дуже
проста майже кожен
воїнів і Героїв Небесної Сотні яким я як
п'ятий президент України присвоїв високе
звання героя
України символом справжнього
українця десятки або сотні тисяч які
стали для того щоби зупинити російську
навалу і російську агресію вони
насправді найкращі українці які
допомогли нам зберегти
державу мільйони волонтерів мільйони
добровольців мільйони громадських
активістів мільйони
небайдужих які зберегли державу бо в
14му році відлік нашого відновлення
незалежно міг зупинитися на цифрі
23 і 30-ї річниці не було би якби
тисячі
тисячі військовослужбовців які сьогодні
вийшли на марш для того щоби
вшанувати 30ту річницю нашої
незалежності ми вітали всіх міжнародних
гостей які разом з нами поділяли нашу
радість Ми з
гордістю дивилися на військовий парад
Тим більше що Два роки поспіль Нам
казали що паради - це
шкідливо два роки Нам казали що на них
не варто виділяти грошей ми їх проводили
безкоштовно а вони їх проводять за 5
млрд
але вже стало доброю
традицією щоби десятки тисяч військових
і цивільних вийшли на День незалежності
для того щоби пройти марш і сотні тисяч
під час і ви це бачили На власні очі
сотні тисяч киян вітали наш
марш серце
зжималося
ніде ви в світі Не знайдете такого
народу як
українці Ніде в світі ви не знайдете
таких людей які би так любили свою
батьківщину так були готові до
самопожертви і так зупинили
агресора Скажіть мені будь ласка яка ще
країна так зупинила агресора як українці
ви не найдете прикладу в
світі і зупинений був і ми звільнили 2
третини окупованого Донбасу дякуючи
доблесті наших
воїнівчи дуже високу ціну Які би Путін
заплатив якби намагався продовжити
наступ і Отже сьогодні з цієї сцени я
хочу подякувати українському народові за
те що він зберіг
незалежність і коли діюча Влада питала А
що ж є
гарантом суверенітету територіальної
цілостсті і незалежності нашої держави
вона діюча влада в наших іноземних
партнерів Я хочу дати відповідь цій
Зеленій владі
гарантом суверенітету Гарант цілісності
і гарантом незалежності нашої держави є
збройні сили України які
ми разом з вами Дорогі українці створили
7 років тому бо їх не
було сьогодні Зелена Влада вийшла хоті
похизуватися тим що вона не робила до
чого вона не має ніякого відношення бо
на сьогоднішній день на
жаль армія її
фінансування було
зупинено ми про це не хотіли
говорити ми говорили про те що ми маємо
рухатися вперед ми маємо об'єднатися ми
маємо продовжити реформи які приведуть
нас до Європейського Союзу до НАТО
бо тільки членство в НАТО а ніякі
будапештські меморандуми є гарантом
безпеки і територіальної цілісності
нашої держави міці наших збройних сил
інших силових
підрозділів а вони в рух НАТО
зупинили і тільки членство в
Європейському Союзі є гарантом добробуту
кожного українця є гарантом демократії
гарантом верховенства
права а вони сьогодні добазікали до того
що вже Європа каже ну на найближчі пть
років принаймні тоді коли ви поки що
Президент перспективу членства ви не
отримаєте Господи сором
який і в цій ситуації і в цій ситуації у
нас
є такі
квакальниці які намагаються нас
зупинити от Я Хочу
наголосити ніхто нас не
зупинить
цього говорити но вимушений
сказати Володимир
Олександровичу я розумію
страшно Я
розумію Я
розумію що
ви
волонтерів
військових справжніх українців боїтеся
більше справжніх патріотів ніж Путіна
Путіну достатньо як ви казали в очі
подивитися стати на коліна і випросити
щось але вам цього не дозволять
зробити
патріоти
громадяни
справжні
українці Я хочу вам сказати Не
намагайтеся нас
зупинити вашою зеленою
шмарклею
[оплески]
У вас нічого не вийде
хоч ви зараз сховали
цих
негідників на банкові уявляєте вони їх
завезли в автозак і сховали їх за лінію
омона Беркута і поліції на вулиці
банковій в офісі президента сором
який я
коли балотувався на пост президента в
14-му я зустрівся з шимоном пересом
великим діячем Вселенського
масштабу я його питав Скажіть будь ласка
що робити з Путіним ви його добре
знаєте Шимон Перес мені сказав я йому
передзвоню і потім вам
відзвонюся і він мені
сказав
нічого доброго ви від Путіна не
чекайте але вам Петре Можу
порадити Не
бійтеся вчитеся в Ізраїлю як він
бореться за власну
незалежність створить свої збройні сили
і на них
покладайтеся я
запам'ятав цю пораду шимона
переса Я зустрічався з
багатьма великими
діячами починаючи від Папи
Римського і закінчуючи найпровідними
лідерами
світу вони були в захоплені від України
від українського народу і казали не
бійтеся Володимир
Олександровичу Не бійтеся
Порошенка Володимире
Олександровичу не бійтеся х десятків
людей які сьогодні зібралися тут для
того щоб
відсвяткувати ювілей
незалежності ми сьогодні святкуємо
Ми сьогодні Для нас це свято бо ми його
виборали бо ми його від 14му1му роках і
Ви не уявляєте що би було з вами якби ви
зіткнулися з такими труднощами як наша
країна зіткнулася в
14-му1му тоді ви по
горлавках бандитів розвлікали тіх хто
вбивав українців А на порогі вашого
стірола вбивали Володимира
рибака бо тоді
ви про Крим казали зі сцени абсолютно
брехливу лайку демотивуючи
українців але зараз вже прийшов
час еволюції від термосу якого ви
уявляли потихе ви до томосу ще Ну
потихенькупустить і армію ви ще не
розумієте але
потихеньку і ветеранів перестанете
боятися і армію буде сприймати як
союзника свого а не ворога і
небезпеку бо ми всі за Україну у нас
немає політичних гасел ми святкуємо своє
свято Бо ми дуже любимо Україну ми
повернемо так як повернули 2ві третини
окупованого Донбасу ми повернемо
останній клаптик української землі хоч
на Донбасі хоч в
Криму ми знову мобілізуємо весь світ
навколо України Україна перестане бути
токсичною і буде
successсторі історію успіху які яку
зробить фантастичній українській народи
Отже Володимир севич Я вітаю вас з 30ю
річницею Незалежності
вивчайте припинить і відпустить цих
бандитів з банківі не ховайте їх їм все
рівно в
Україні
некомфортно
Якщо хтось шукає де реалізувати свої
таланти
Приєднуйтесь Мені приємно бачити прапори
справи громад круто мені приємно бачити
прапори Брати по зброї дуже круто і дуже
приємно Мені було бачити як вітали
братів по зброї справу громад Кияни і
гості Києва які сьогодні вишукувалися
вітали і кричали так
тримати
вони кричали Україна
переможе вони кричали Крим - це Україна
Донбас - це
Україна і вони кричали те що нарешті нас
тіх об'єднує вже см років і це
звучить Слава Україні Героям слава Слава
нації Смерть ворога Україна понад усе
Україна понад усе Україна понад усе
а далі Володимир Олександрович якщо ви
щось не дочули Нехай вам прокрутять що
наші десантники кричали на репетиції
параду Вони все правильно кричали це
було супер друзі дуже дякую спасибі що
ви не байдужі Спасибі що ми зібралися
тут Спасибі що нас з вами ніхто не
зупинить і вже ніхто не бачить як во
намагалися щоби ця Зеленка перешкодила
нам нашому маршу як вони намагалися щоб
вона зупинила
мене запам'ятайте ніяка
зелі нас не зупинить Слава
Україні
Дякую п'ятий президент України Петро
Порошенко і Марина
Порошенко президент який створює і будує
армії і боронить українську державу
той хто не побоявся взяти
відповідальність той хто став на чолі
воюючої країни п'ятий президент України
Петро
[оплески]
[музика]
порошенкомимимимимими п'ятий
стане СМИ п'ятий стане сомим п'ятий
стане
смим наші слова та богу до вух хай так і
буде брати і сестри а зараз на нашій
сцені вже завершив підготовку наступний
гурт це він же за доволі короткий час
став легендою легендою справжньою
легендою української
сцени Вони
почали працювати якщо я не помиляюсь в
11му чи в 12-му році але вже за цей
короткий час вони встигли об'їхати мало
чи не весь світ їх знають за океаном їх
знає Вся Європа і А якщо дозволиш а їх
пісню Подай зброю мені брате Зачекай
мила Зачекай мати співають на усіх
тарентах східного фронту України і
заряджаються на
перемогу рядимось Ми всі з вами тому що
на сцені козак
[музика]
систем Привіт
Привіт Я вас не чую Привіт
Привіт О інша справа Добрий вечір
друзі з Днем Незалежності вас
ми довго чекали цієї зустрічі тут жива
трансляція у нас сьогодні тому все Чесно
Все наживо і сьогодні з вами козак систм
цей важливий для нас для кожного
українця день Де ваші
[музика]
руки зазирни під мою шкіру
там ціле небо
журавлів там ще не вигатали
Віру і море повне
кораблів там ріки тихі
повноводні годують землю молоком
[музика]
що ти побачила сьогодні
за цим відчиненим вікном
вікном моє серце
шу мої мрії
мої сни Хто як не ти Веде мене туди в
небі журавлі хто Як нети хто як не ти
іди на на землі видеш мене
туди як
[музика]
дети я сам у руки твої
лезу якщо захочеш
покладу бо я від
тебетверези та все одно до тебе
йду я майже Віру твого
[музика]
тіла прийняв за істину в собі
перерисе Чого
хотіла я віддаю лише тобі
тобі моє серце мою
душу мой мрі
мосни Хто як не ти Веде мене туди де в
небі жлі хто
яти Хто як не ти єдина на землі Ведеш
мене туди Хто як не
[музика]
ти
[оплески]
[музика]
моє серце мою душу мої мрі
мої сни Хто як не ти Веде мене туди де
мене
біі Хто як не ти хто як не ти єдина на
землі живи ди Хто як не ти хто як не ти
хто як не ти хто як не ти хто як не ти
хто як не ти хто як не ти хто як не не
Ти хто як не
[музика]
ти Дякуємо дякуєм
Дякуємо наступну пісню де б ми не грали
в якому місці України чи за кордоном ми
б не грали ми завжди цю пісню
присвячуємо українським
воїнам дайте дайте
шуму сьогоднішня незалежність це не на
пустому місці кожен день там на сході
триває війна війна на якій гинуть наші з
вами побратими і посестри тому давайте
цінувати кожен день цієї Незалежності
незалежність це не разовий акт
незалежність - це процес це Як здоров'я
про здоров'я не можна дбати один деньдва
дні Доки будеш живий Доки будеш
здоровий Все буде добре Тому я бажаю
кожному ва здоров'я Я бажаю нашій
Україні здоров'я Я бажаю сили натхнення
і поступу
[музика]
вперед Співаємо
разом запозичені
речення з
[музика]
книжок Ну скажи
хіба не фантастично
що у цьому хаосі доріг під суворим небом
небом вічним я тебе
зустрів і не
[музика]
зберіг нуно скажи хіба не
фантастично що у цьому хаосі доріг
під суворим небом небом вічним я тебе
зустрі і не
збері ти Я свічне як і небо доки
мерехтітимуть світи буду я Приходити до
тебе і до інших тимуть
гордіти Як все бутенно Як все
звично скільки раз це чила земля Але ми
з тобою ми не вічні ми з тобою просто ти
і я як буденно як все
звично скільки раз це бачила
земля Але ми з тобою ми не вічні ми з
тобою просто ти і
[музика]
я
Ну скажи хіба це не печально що життя
без гриму і
прикрас розкидало штормом п'ятибальним
наші зни так само як і нас доля часто є
несправедлива там і тут так само як і
скрізь якось буду я ти Будь
щаслива з тобою більше не
зійти Як все буденно Як все
звичного скільки раз це бачила земля Але
ми з тобою ми не вічні ми з тобою просто
ти і я як будетем все
звич скільки раз це бачила
земля Але ми з тобою не мині ми з тобою
просто ти і
[музика]
[оплески]
я
[музика]
Як все буденно Як все
звично скільки раз це бачила земля Але
ми з тобою ми не вічні ми з тобою просто
ти і я як будено як все звично скільки
раз це бачила земля Але ми з тобою ми не
вічні ми з тобою просто ти і я і тому
для мене так трагічно те що ти чияся не
моя і тому для мене так трагічно те що
ти чиясь а не моя і тому для мене так
трагічно те що ти чиясь а не моя і тому
для мене так трагічно те що ти чи
а не моя а не
[музика]
моя
постукала в
двері з ранковим
дощем вірвалась
копила
тримає я б їй
написав 100 віршів і
поеми та я її зовсім не знаю
ні
мії ні щоденних дорів ні друзів Ні
рідних
ніколи я взяв її руку Якби тільки мі
приклав до серця до
свого осені очі
твої і я закохався і тебе не була б
зараз ти
[музика]
у осені очі твої
мій
світвірвався у осені очі
твої І я б не
питав в неї з ким вона
спить по кому квітки її
сохнуть я б слухав із нею
як клен
шелестить як в жовтні садки мертво
мокнуть не зназнаю ні вулиць ні дат ні
адрес розмірів ніх ні
герої ні віршів улюблених ні поетес
нічого Та все ж я з тобою
співочесні очі
мої і я закохався і тебе не було б зараз
де Ти де Ти де Де ти Де
ти осені очі
твої
вірвась всні очі
[музика]
твої
і поки не
знаю триваєця
гра і мій інтерес рветься
далі
спокусливо
хвора осіння
пора полює на душі і
металі
постухало в двері з ранковим
дощем вірвалась хопила
тримає я б їй написав 100 віршів і поем
Та я її зовсім не знаю осінь очі твої
разом
осені очі
твої я закохався ітебе не була б зараз
ти де ти де ти де ти дайте
шуму в осені очі
твої мій світ обірвався у осені очі
твої і дуже-дуже голосно пер
усні у
і детебе не була б заразти де ти де ти
де ти де
ти осені
[музика]
Мій світ
обірвався осені очі
[музика]
твої
Ну що ручки догори
[музика]
друзі ручки ручки всі ручки Я вас всіх
бачу гй там на схилах я вас бачу ручки
підняли всі п
[музика]
п
put Your Hands
[музика]
together наша маланька боса
ходила наша
маланька воду носила воду носила
роси
збивала наша
малаком
[музика]
літа
воду насила роси
збивала наша
маленька Пахом
літала Пахом
літала небом
лукала наша
маленька Бога
шукала
[музика]
співаче поле тепер підняли руки ваші в
гору
О
І раз два раз два раз два
[музика]
тричо почалися короводи Це дуже гарно
доєднуємося до
[музика]
короводів наша
малаганка бося
ходила наша
Маланка воду
носила воду носила
роси
збивала наша
маланька баком
літала
[музика]
[оплески]
сотні літо дощі та райдуги цілунки легко
стають окусами на сквізний струм в
потоках патики Твоя порядність така
зпокуслова не я лювлюполині постощ не я
життя вимірюю курсами твої конспекти і
зайві ремнощі Твоя порядність така
спокуслива така
спокуслива така спокуслива Усе я що я
мушу вивчити усе я що я хочу відати ти
ти ти
ти усе є що я мушу вичити усе є що я
хочу віддати ти
ти ти
[музика]
іти
твоя відсутність така заплутана твої
приходи такі наповнені ти недочута ти
переслухана ти Боже вільнава на твої
симптоми твої діагнози тешинтві і серце
Ісусове температура високі
градусиі така
спокуслива така
спокуслива така спокуслива у
щоти уе то якщо я хочу вітати ти ти ти
ти все тоє що я мушу вивчити тоє що я
хочу ти ти ти
молодці д д д всі стрибають всі
[музика]
стрибають
[оплески]
соло акордеон
Іва лень
[музика]
нічна теорія східні практики вино з
горсупа вітер з Атлантики Так дивно бути
зю коли Свобода найвищий поверх ти
божевільна ти некерована ти недочута ти
переслухана твоя відсутність така
заплутана твоя присутність така
наповнена така
наповнена така наповнена все тоє що я
мушу вивчити всесе тоє що я хочу віддати
ти ти ти ти ще ще ще ще ще Усе твоє що я
ш чу вивчити усе то я що я хочу віддати
ти ти ти
ти усе то я що я мушу вивчити усе і що я
хочу віддати ти ти ти
ти усе воє що вивчити усе твоє що я хочу
віддати ти ти ти
ти
[музика]
[оплески]
Дякуємо
друзі сад вишневий
стежка зараз нам потрібні ваші руки
вгору вгору вгору І ті хто там
[музика]
позаду готові
щлинь скорі нам кохатись доля я
ретова
[музика]
[оплески]
Рева
[музика]
Тримай свою хвилю гриби свою милю не
думай про гроші не слухай про гри
півтисячі спилось вві сотні втопилось А
ти ще живи тільки голос закрив не все
так погано є маріхуана брикетик по ерху
тютюн на здогін а ти ніби гриб посміхоюш
що зверхнього маєш свій ласлий в силу це
він хрепи свою пісню живи легковісно
важке Ні до рука Ні до голови покиряй
проблеми буть завжди у хні в темпі
хорошому проросто
живи живи і люби доки В тебе є сила
Збирайся на долю могутнім плечем п Яка в
тебе хвиля тепер не на крилах пиши свою
книгу вогнени
[музика]
мечем тобі говорили бочемним і Ми
співали про нраві права мовляв
заспокойся не бийся Не бойся але чого
варті солодкі слова ці люди і збати
живуть до зарплати або ж до розплати що
їм не кажи їх легко купити їх легко
продати ти вони ніби речі немає душі
забиє на своботу ти маєш породу ІС ніби
запах сирої трави іходи у гнах і кровчу
ленах кричить не здавайся благає живи
живи і люби
під тебе є сила Збирайся на воду
могутнім пличем я там тебе хвиля тепер
нена крила Пиши свою книгу вог
[музика]
меча золу на
пасу Володимир
шесу
[музика]
Живи і люби доки В тебе є сила збирай на
долю могутні плечем Яка в тебе хвиля
тепер не накрила пиши свою книгу гнени
мечем Живи люби Поки в тебе є сила
Збирайся на долю могутнім плечем Яка в
тебе хвиляла
щ свою книгу вогнемімече
чути і люби доки В тебе є сила збираюся
на долю могутнім плечем Яка в тебе хвиля
тепер не на крила Пиши свою книгу
[музика]
bхrммеşem
Дякуємо Дорогі українці з вами були
козак систem і ще раз З днем
незалежності вас і слава
[оплески]
Україні
Козаки козак
[музика]
сим Так у нас схоже є
сувенір ми можемо зараз організувати
благодійний аукціон і продати цього
акордеона Іванко тобі треба акордеон Я
думаю що йому треба акордеон тому що в
нього же купа концертів і зокрема
сьогодні так що
нуємо Але в нас але в нас можливо є
сувенір а можливо ми втрафимо комусь
віддати загублену річ Медаль за єдність
України Хлопці хто прийшов з медалями і
з орденами або дівчата будь ла або
дівчата Перепрошую передивіться будь
ласка на свої лацкани на свої кітіля Чи
ви нічого не згубили якщо хтось згубив
Медаль за єдність України з тризубом
військовим і колоском то будь ласка сіди
до мене на сцену зразу і
сфоткаємося ми не
неодмінночекаємо чекаємо якщо ви
загубили медаль Або якщо ви просто
хочете сфотографуватись приходьте за
сцену ми завжди є тут на місці
що шановне товариство ми продовжуємо
наше святкове дійство і так ще попереду
багато чудових виступів але в цей момент
Ми би хотіли згадати А які були здобутки
нашої Незалежності новітньої
Незалежності за ці 30 років тому що
насправді чи не каждого року траплялося
щось таке що для нас стало Ще
однієюходинкою для побудови сильної і
успішної української держа
Браття і сестри от Скажіть будь ласка 30
років це багато чи
мало
малод в розрязі на життя це можна
сказати це є половина або третина
людського життя а в розрізі
тисячолітньої історії однозначно то є
мало але навіть незважаючи на те що 30
років на нашу з вами спільну думку то є
таке мало ті 30 років мали певні
сходинки вони мали певні етапи і ми би
дуже хотіли згадати ті етапи оті віхи
української незалежності разом із вами
увага на
[музика]
екрани жовтень
1990 року Революція на ті перший масовий
протест студентської молоді з
політичними вимогами непідписання нового
союзного договору відставка прем'єра
перевибори до Верховної ради та ряд
інших сячі синьо-жовтих прапорів
замойоріли над площею яка згодом стане
майданом Незалежності Це вже було
творення нової держави
України
народу
[музика]
на проголошення незалежності України 24
серпня
1991 року сталася історична подія
Верховна Рада Української Радянської
Соціалістичної Республіки
ухвалила
у а вже 1 грудня 91 року на
всеукраїнському референдумі понад 90%
громадян сказали Так незалежності
[музика]
України 28
червня96 року Верховна Рада України
прийняла І ввела в дію основний закон
Конституцію України гарантію наших прав
і
свобод серпень
1996 року в Україні введено в обіг
національну валюту відтепер українську
гривню представляють видатні постаті
нашої історії Володимир Великий Ярослав
Мудрий богдан Хмельницький Іван Мазепа
іва
Шевський Тарас Шевченко Григорій
Сковорода Леся Українка та Володимир
вернадкий 2004
ріква
революція проходять масові акції
протесту проти фальсифікації виборів
президента протестувальники мирним
шляхом домоглися проведення повторного
другого туру
у результаті голосування перемогу здобув
Віктор Ющенко розпочато рух до
Європейського Союзу та НАТО відновлено
історичну справедливість щодо постатей
подій українського державотворення
розкрито правду про
Голодомор пам'ять про Голодомор - це
ліки які рятують Україну від духовної
летаргії і кончини у темних водах чужих
миров робимо те що повинні робити Будьмо
ра завжди нехай допоможе нам Господь
[музика]
листопад
2013 лютий 2014 років Революція Гідності
хвилі протестів сколихнули всю Україну
як реакція на відмову керівництва
держави від курсу на
євроінтеграціюдушення акції протесту
закінчилося кривавою роз майданівцями
розстрілом Небесної Сотні українці
повстали на захист Свободи гідності прав
людини і європейського майбутнього
України народ України домігся повалення
режиму Януковича та дочасних виборів
президента України правда
перемогла
лютий березень 14го року військо
Московської Федерації захопило Кримський
півострів після ганебної втечі Януковича
та проведення незаконного референдуму у
Криму розпочалися переслідування
ув'язнення українських активістів та
кримських татар які тривають і до
сьогодні однак українці не боялися і не
бояться демонструвати відданість державі
Курсанти академії військово-морських сил
імені Нахімова у Севастополі відмовилися
давати присягу на вірність Московії та
під час церемонії зміни українського
прапора на Московській співали гімн
України Крим - це Україна
поможем за нашу
свободу і
покаже що ми браття коза
квітень
2014 початок російської з агресії проти
України на Донбасі тимчасова окупація
частини Луганської областей втрати
України у російсько-українській війні
становлять за даними ООН понад 13 000
загиблих з них більше 4 000 українських
військовослужбовців понад 30 000
поранених 2 млни тимчасово перемі
Московська агресія триває
досі покаже що ми
[музика]
[оплески]
братя пане президент у центральній мі
площі міста армовсь
16 дві хвилини Дозвольте підняти прапор
України 1 липня 2014 року силовими
України розпочата повномасштабна
військова операція з активного
контрнаступу по всій лінії фронту в
результаті звільнено 17 населених
пунктів і серед них Слов'янськ
Краматорськ Костянтинівка Дружківка
Бахмут загалом майже 2/3 окупованої
території на сході украї звільнено
Московії довелося розпочати безпосереднє
вторгнення регулярними військами щоб
зберегти під контролем ча української
території та боротьба триває і ми
боротимемося за кожен сантиметр
української
землі реформа збройних сил України
відновлення впк та старт розробки
ракетних програм Нептун та вільха
реформа речового продовольчого та
житлового забезпечення
створення сил спеціальних операцій
навесні
буликраїнських військових у 2018 році
українське військо у топ-10 армій Європи
і у армії
[музика]
світу
українаєваний безвіз 17 травня 2017 року
у страсбурзі в європарламенті за
присутності президента України Петра
Порошенка відбулась урочиста церемонія
підписання законо акту яким
запроваджується безвізовий режим для
громадян України
подія безвізу українці здійснили понад
50 мльйонів поїздок до ЄС і так Україна
- це
Європа
томос про
автокефалію нарешті відновлено історичну
справедливість і в Україні з'явилась
незалежна православна церква на базі
раніше невизначе невизнаних Української
Православної Церкви Київського
Патріархату Автокефальної Православної
Церкви та частини Московської церкви 15
грудня 2018 року під наглядом
представників Вселенського Патріарха в
Україні відбувся об'єднавчий собор на
якому створили православну церкву
України та обрали митрополитом Київським
епіфанія 6 січня Він отримав томус про
автокефалію від Вселенського Патріарха
українська церква повернулася
додому а з приходом некомпетентних
керівників які неодноразово
демонстрували байдужість та зневагу до
цінностей здобутків української армії в
українців сформувалася нова
традиція 4 серпня у День незалежності
України учасники московсько-української
війни а також волонтери патріоти
небайдужі громадяни проходять врочистою
ходою центральними вулицями міста як
свідчення сили духу боротьби за свободу
та віри у перемогу над ворогом Україна
понад
усе і сьогодні серед нас брати і сестри
є багато учасників цієї щорічної Ходи на
День незалежності щорічного маршу
патріотів і ми на цю сцену з превеликим
задоволенням і щестю Запрошуємо учасника
російсько-української війни ветерана
95-ї аеромобільної бригади Олександра
[оплески]
погребиського
Слава
нації Слава нації Смерть ворога Слава
Нації Смерть
ворога
запам'ятайте наш
Ворог буде
[оплески]
гинути
як склав одну дуже чудову На мою думку
фразу сучасний виконавець
Ми Українці дуже
часто пишаємось
тими за
Україну Але я вважаю що настав час
пишатись тими хто зарани неї живе І
шанувати тих
хто ціною свого
життя її зберіг для нас з
вами рівно рік
тому ми також йшли на
марші
нашим підрозділом учас
російсько-української війни у кількості
приблизно
чоловік
сьогодні нас вже були
сотні А за нами
йшли наші громадяни
грома підтримку яких ми
відчуваємо завжди у найскладніші
хвилини нашої нашого
життя
і Я впевнений що братів по
зброї буде ставати тисячі по всій
території України і ці тисячі зметуть цю
зелену плісняву з лицця гордої
української
держави
сьогодні на марші
це ганьба влади
Зеленського сьогоднішній інцидент з
зеленкою біля
каплички Героїв Небесної Сотні
це не
провокація проти Петра
Порошенка це провокація проти Героїв
Небесної Сотні
це
провокація проти сім'ї загиблого журавля
який знаходився поряд
це
провокація
проти
російсько-української війни а значить
проти української державності
і Я
гордий
що такого лідера як Петро
Порошенко який через годину вже стояв на
сцені і посміхався в
обличчю
авторам цього
абсурду там були не ветерани Як сьогодні
відмічають які
ватно-зелені
ЗМІ там була група молодих маргінальних
людей які за гроші готові продати рідну
мати Бо у
жодного в голові не з'явиться ніколи
ідея
обливати героїв пам'ять героїв Небесної
Сотні І сім'ї загиблих
та своїх
побратимів і Я
впевнений що
Кара цих людей по життю застане такий
закон життя і його ніхто ніколи не
відміняв а Україна буде міцнішати
авторитет учасників війни буде
кріпшати і
наш
авіаносець розмете всю зелену
плісняву і головна зелена жаба
втече в своє
болото Слава
[оплески]
Україні Україні потрібні
українці яким
Україні потрібні
Українці які здатні дати бій Україні
потрібні українці Які навіть якщо
пересварені між собою то в час найвищої
небезпеки для держави вміють зібратися в
один кулак і дати відсіч і нарешті
вибороти омріяну українську державність
друзі Я знаю що тут зібралися ті хто
знають що для них є Україна
Так я знаю що тут є
ті хто не говорить що Україна дала для
мене а говорять що я можу зробити для
України Так Так тут зібралися патріоти
тут зібралися ті які
небайдужі тому що патріотизм то є
небайдужість інакше Коли ми не мовчимо
коли ми говоримо правду і хай би вона
була колюча то є
патріотизм коли ми відстоїмо право
домінації української мови то є
небайдужість то є патріотизм і я знаю ті
хто тут зібралися є саме такими
небайдужими
Саме так чи
ні тому ми наближаємося до
кульмінаційної точки нашого
сьогоднінього концерту І Я запрошую на
сцену людину який один з перших в
незалежній Україні почав співати правду
Тарас
Чубай
зустрічайте
[музика]
Дай Боже щастя Як справи
добре що вас трохи
є Святом Незалежності
України зараз я хотів би разом з вами
заспівати
гімн який став гімном Українського
війська колись був гімном Організації
українських
націоналістів
[музика]
зродились ми дикої години З пожеж війни
із полумя огнів лекав нас біль по втраті
України коми нас Гнів і злість на
ворогів лекав нас
більі України кормив нас Ів ізр
[музика]
ворогів і
о му бою життєвому в
всі не зламнімо в граніт бо плач не дав
Свободи ще нікому А хто борець тойє свій
поплач не дав Свободи ще нікому А хто
борець той здобуває
[музика]
зві
доволі нам руїни і незгоди Не сміє Брат
на брата йти у бій ід синьо жовтим
прапором Свободи зєднаєм
весьй нарі свій під синьо-жовтим
кравом Свободи зіднаєм весь великий
[музика]
на веде нас бій
борглих Слава для нас закон найвищий то
наказ
Соборна українська є держава міцна й
одна відсяну по Кавказ
Соборна
українська є держава міцна й одна
відсяну по
Кавказ
Дякую
[музика]
вам наступну пісню Я хочу
присвятити всім бійцям полеглим
раненим і тим що зараз нас обороняють і
тим що будуть нас
обороняти Дякуємо вам хлопці і зараз
пісня для вас
[музика]
Буде
нам з тобою що
[музика]
згадати після довгих
збавлених
[музика]
ночей я далеки звук
гарматний і
тривожний блиск твоїх
очей вивчу я далекий звук
гарматний і
тривожний блиск твоїх
[музика]
очей твої
о квіти
темно-сині на
узбічі
радісних
доріг чи
зустрінемось з тобою
знову на
своїх
дорога
бойових чи
зустрінемось з тобою знов
на
своїх
дорогах
бойових будуть стріль
нарозриватись
глухо і
дрижати у вибухах
земля
вив тусто сторону
Послухай де в
багряних полум'ях
поля вийдеш Ти в ту сторону
[музика]
Послухай де в
багряних полум'ях
полях і почув єш грізну борню
волі і
вкриється кров'ю битий
[музика]
шлях бу хлопці йти
суворочолі ВС
сіруватих наче ніч
рядах будуть
хлопці йти
суворочолі в
сіруватих наче ніч
[музика]
рядах і
пройдуть вони безмежним
краєм кріз руїни сіл дерев і
трав і
напевно ти тоді
згадаєш хто любов і
мужність
поєднав і
напевно ти тоді
згадаєш хто
любов і
мужність
[музика]
поєдна дякую
вам
[музика]
Коли до губ
твоїх
лишається
півподиху Коли до губ
твоїх лишається
півкроку
зіниці
твої виткані
ізподиву в очах у тебе синьо і широко
що щепшеш
зачаровано і тихо
ти той щепід мою тишу
синьокрає і забуваю я що вмію
[музика]
дихати І що ходити вмі
забуваю та чорний втах
пові
здіймається і впевненість мою кудись
відмає неступленим
півкроку
залишається
півподиху у
горлі
[музика]
застрягає сіниці твої виткані із
подиву в очах у тебе синьо і
широко але до губ твоїх
лишається
півподиху
до губ твоїх
лишається
[музика]
півкроку до губ твоїх лишається
півподиху до губ твоїх лишається
[музика]
півкроку
дякую
вам друзі Приходьте ближче сюди
поспіваємо бо я вас так чути не буду Ах
готовий співати разом Давай Ану
перевіримо зараз Ах лента за лентою
набої подавай український повстанче в
бою не відступай ану всі
разом Слава
україніла о
тричотири А лента за лентою набої
подавай українській повстаньче в бою не
вступай всі разом
лента український повстань ще в бою не
відступай вже вечір вечоріє повстанське
серце б'є А лента набої поспішно модає
всі разом лента та на
український повстанче в бою не відступай
не чую лента за лентою набой подавай
український повстанчи в бою не відступай
а ворог атакує і прецящо сил юнак
кулеметник їхправно косив
ахлента набой подавай українській
повстанче в бою нестпай всі разом
[музика]
як сонце Сходило втомлений юнак упав він
ранений упав він навзнак А
[музика]
лента український повстаньче в бою не
відступай всі
разом на бої подалай український
повстаньче в бою не відступає він в неї
вдивляєсь пече Пардон не ті слова до
нього санітарка поспішно іде в обличчя
вдивляєсь його впізнає Ах лента за
лентою напої подавай український
повстань ще в бою не відступай гей
лентакою
навай
поюхай він в неї вдивляєсь спече в
грудях рана біля кулемета а дівчина
молода Ей
лентаю
нава український повстаньче в бою не
відступав всі
разомю набої подавай
українціюуй гей лента за
[музика]
лентою
ле а ворог атакує останній момент наново
заграв вже затихли кулеме гей
[музика]
лента лента за
лентою країнсь
повста гй лента за лентою на пої подавай
країнські повстаньчи бою не виступай не
[музика]
чую
дякуювам дякую
зараз я хочу
заграти композицію яку може ви трохи всі
забули її можна асоціювати
з не знаю напевно з подіями в
крутах битвою під Крутами скорше всього
такі образи мені принаймні виникали коли
я писав музику на чудовий вірш Костя
москальця срібне
поле
[музика]
сутінковими птахами поросла твоя мила і
втраче
назва музика ледве засніжена за теплими
мурами
сліз томуючи землю й світло погляньмо на
поле
срібне теплим небом налите повінця
темним небом наповнене в Шер теплим
небом налите повінця темним небом на щер
сріб с сібне
поле срібне сібне
[музика]
поле срібне срібне
полене срібне
[оплески]
[музика]
поле
тож повився мов дикий сіди виноград Моя
смертонько мила Я
плачу коли трохи ущухне твердий листопад
коли попіл ущухне кого ми
[музика]
побачим таммуючи землю світло погляньмо
на
поле теплим небом налите повінця
ним небом наповнене щель теплим небом
налите полінця темним небом наповнене
щер срібне срібне
поле срібне срібне
поле срібне Срібне
[музика]
срібне срібне
полетінковими
птахами твоя мила і
назва музика ледве засніжена Зате мурами
сліз тамуючись землю і світлом погляньмо
на поле
срібне теплим небом налите повінця
темним небом наповненем ще теплим небом
малите поїнця темним небом наповнене в
щерть світне світне
поле
срібнерібне
[музика]
поле
срібне
поле срібне срібне
[оплески]
поле срібне срібне срібне срібне
поле срібне сібне
поле срібне сіне
полене
поле срібне срібне
[музика]
поле срібне
поле срібне срібне
[музика]
поле
Дякую
вам Браво
це чудова пісня Дякую я теж її люблю
а пропоную зараз
ее знову такого трошки до військової
тематики і пригадати собі часи ще до
Першої світової
війни от як тоді ставилися українці до
служби в
[музика]
війську чи хотіли вони йти служити і
зараз буде композиція кедьми прийшла
карта
щось слабо дайте
[оплески]
[музика]
шла
нарувався став я свого не
[музика]
тут так караокі пішло голосно що я себе
не чую
ки тихіше
зроби
Дякую
вам дякую
[музика]
Вам
червону
[музика]
руду
вечорами ти у мене є Дина
ти
ї о моя
рода тоє
чиная
вода тоє
[музика]
наяда тоє
быстрая вода сині
гір тоє
бистрая вода сині
[музика]
гіра то є
бистрая
вода
синій
[музика]
[оплески]
гі Слава
Україні
[музика]